ou les titles Tuesday
chase.com/h eventschool tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue yosh sur ce
nouveau stream
pour moi aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir
on a une super affiche ici devant nous
avec Mad Carlson avec les Blancs contre
un niche guéri donc c'est un beau petit
derby je crois cette partie ils ont le
département du jouet
combien de fois ensemble ce soir
ensemble et
a gagné deux fois contre scène lors de
leur toute première confrontation en
particulier classique j'entends et lors
de leur toute dernière confrontation
donc il est pendant très longtemps il
est resté avec plus un contre Magnus
donc il avait gagné la première partie
je crois jusqu'à nez quand il avait
peut-être 16 ans il était très très
jeune c'était sa première participation
au tournoi art de vivre ensuite
énormément de nuls et une fois que
Magnus a pu remporter une première
partie il en a enchaîné plusieurs je
crois une monnaie 5 1 ou quelque chose
comme ça et mais là il a perdu lors de
Vichy à nouveau en janvier dernier
et ils ont pas rejoint en partie
classique depuis donc
Magnus qui doit être hyper en colère ne
pas avoir gagné déjà depuis quatre
parties qui jouent un de ces un de ces
grands rivaux alors c'est pas du point
de vue chaque jour était en dessous
c'est moins rival que de la valeur ou
que les Fabiano Caravana ou à les
razafiroga mais avec en plus le côté
Twitter chambrage etc des histoires je
pense qu'il prend cette partie très à
coeur et elle s'appromait un gros
spectacle je pense que c'est une partie
qui pour tous les deux est assez
importante c'est à dire que tu sais que
tu viens de le dire tu parles des tweets
et très souvent en fait et ben on a on a
des beaux petits tweets après leur
partie après leur confrontation
donc il se moque un petit peu de l'un et
l'autre mais bon c'est bon enfant ça
reste
[Musique]
un petit passage il y a un an où c'était
un peu moins ballon qui s'appelle que
d'habitude
[Musique]
regarde pas ah non il y avait eu un
moment c'était c'était assez mauvaise
enfant on va dire oui c'était c'était un
petit peu c'était un petit peu un petit
peu chaud mais maintenant ok c'est
devenu un peu un
interdit quoi
je sais pas à
quel point mais en tout cas il y a
forcément une forme de respect aussi
d'admiration etc mais
mais un mec là maintenant c'est vraiment
envie de lui coller donc il a fait un
choix d'ouverture
de catalan un peu chelou avec lequel on
se croit aussi rapidement
enfin moi ça me surprend mais c'est pas
du tout quelque chose que je maîtrise la
Catalane mais donc Magnus en a joué déjà
au championnat du monde même quand on
n'est pas venu ici lors de son dernier
Championnat du monde de catalan mais
je connais pas trop la même qu'elle a
laissé trois là bon on peut expliquer
pourquoi Sarah après on va expliquer
pourquoi c'est naturel mais on peut
expliquer aussi peut-être pourquoi Sarah
je passe tu viens juste les premiers
coups d'ailleurs on peut la regarder
depuis le début peut-être pas expliquer
ce que c'est que la catalane et tout ça
je vais rentrer la partie je sais que je
n'ai pas eu le temps de faire alors des
cas le 6 C4 E6 cavaler F3 D5 et G3 OK et
j'ai trois donc le coup qui caractérise
la défense catalogue
une petite ouverture mais jusqu'à ce que
cramling dans les années 2000 se mettre
à la jouer avec d'excellents résultats
plus haut niveau et c'est devenu
maintenant une belle ligne principale
pour les blancs après des quatre
donc rock des princesca
ouvert de la Catalane on peut aussi
jouer évidemment avec Cécile ou autre
donc d'habitude les Blancs jouent damso
cavaliers les deux ou cavaliers 5 on va
essayer de l'organiser assez vite
c'est réputé pour être enfin j'allume je
l'ordinateur je vois que l'ordinateur
est déjà un avantage noir donc est-ce
que c'est une c'est une nouveauté ouais
c'est ça
[Musique]
le noir vont prendre réponse à cavaliers
ça peut paraître ça peut paraître très
naturel par exemple à la place de roquet
on rend accès évidemment naturelle on se
dit bah je développe le caméléon
non pas du tout dans la Catalane on
attend avec le camembert pour souvent
venir en des deux ou même en C3 il peut
être très mal placé si on imagine que
les Noirs jouent C6 V5 par exemple comme
ça arrive souvent en installant puis en
bas 5 pour protéger le plan C4 quand les
blancs essayent de le miner ensuite par
1 2 à 4 il va y avoir B4 avec un temps
sur lequel c'est 3 donc
pas toujours bien placé alors après ça
reste un coup de développement vers le
centre ça l'idée c'est de faire 4
aussi mais donc voilà ma news qui est
venue avec sa petite variante
ma peau déstabiliser un échec qui est un
des un des joueurs les mieux préparés
peut-être même le mieux préparé au monde
donc ouais c'est une surprise qui peut
peut-être le faire prendre un peu de
mauvaise décision
[Musique]
salut chaleureusement qui nous disent
une prépa leur impressionnet c'est
l'école française de la souffrance alors
Laurent il est en train de jouer au Top
16 à charbon je pense pas qu'il seconde
mainus pour ce tournoi
mais bon alors après ça peut être une
vieille idée de Laurent mais
là en tout cas il est pas il est pas là
pour pendant
là je passe t'abus cette interview
norvégienne ou
il a dit qu'il en pouvait vraiment plus
de se préparer quoi qu'il adorait les
échecs classiques de manière générale
qu'il trouve ça cool
[Musique]
à des positions de chaque c'est sympa
mais juste la prépa ça le sous le plus
au moins
ouais ben c'est sûr quand ça fait en
fait il est relativement jeune encore
mais en 90
mais en fait ça fait déjà 20 ans qu'il
est grand maître quoi donc il y a un
moment t'en peux plus quoi quand tu fais
une centaine de parties classiques par
an depuis 20 ans et que pour chaque
partie classique tu te prépares pendant
deux heures à 22h
un moment ça peut devenir lassant je
comprends bien mais c'est le métier
donc des Français 4 alors la partie il y
a eu cavalier C3 ici et sur qu'est-ce
qu'on ajoute cavaler ses 6 alors c'est
un coup un petit peu étrange
généralement dans les potions de D4 on
voit rarement le cavaler venir en C6
généralement c'est plus par D7 quand le
développement
donc l'idée
ça met la pression sur le plan des
quatre et du coup ça scotche un peu le
cavalier à froid parce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer que vu que les blancs vont pas
regarder le plan C4 ni par daccès de
dames français 4 ni par cavalier
des deux ou cavaliers à trois qui allait
prendre ces quatre on pouvait imaginer 5
mais où cavalier F3 en D2 sauf que là
avec la pression sur le plan de 4 ça a
l'air compromis
mais bon une autre idée ça aurait été de
préparer la poussette mais d'ailleurs
c'est pas c'est pas impossible que
l'idée d'Aniche ça soit de jouer après
tour B8 et M5
parce que bah déjà ça protège le premier
5 mais surtout ça enlève la tour de la
grande diagonale ou le faux catalan mais
[Musique]
pour défendre ces quatre donc tu peux
t'accrocher c'est pour ça en fait que du
coup généralement c'est un groupe
bizarre c'est un coup étrange en tout
cas c'est un coup que je compte pas mes
élèves généralement vous savez quand on
joue ces positions une structure avec C6
mais cavaler ces 6 c'est un coup qui bon
voilà c'est qui la joue donc j'ai résumé
qu'il a clairement des idées mais c'est
un goût qui est qui est assez
intéressant mais encore une fois c'est
une exception
en fait le coup le coup de mainus c'est
aussi un peu surprenant donc ça peut
paraître très naturel avec les yeux d'un
débutant de se dire mais attends il fait
le centre parfait le chat enfin tu vois
de quatre les noirs n'ont pas de pions
dans le carré central c'est tout à fait
normal alors oui vu comme ça c'est ça
paraît normal sauf que ça a quand même
des gros défauts bon le premier c'est
que ça peut bloquer le 2 sur sa grande
diagonale mais ça a fait plus des cases
notamment la case de Troie
en tout cas les C6 peut tout à fait
alors en B4 allant des trois dans des
variantes et ça peut ça peut venir très
vite quoi ce truc donc
bon c'est vraiment la variante de manus
mais là d'ailleurs non on le voit pas
ça serait intéressant de voir assis à
l'écran ouais donc à niche qui a l'air
un peu en mode réflexion de levé est-ce
que tu peux juste remettre 2 secondes
pour nous en tout cas
l'arme d'ouverture de Dotcom pour voir à
quel point c'est rare ce couvre
en tout une quarantaine de fois donc
pour voir si
dans la position là s'il y a d'autres
couleurs
et du coup de permettre qu'à valider F3
de 2 qui avait les Français 4
donc là alors parfois les Noirs
s'accrochent au pion c'est un peu
montrer une idée typique de la Catalane
tu retrouves par exemple pour B8 pour
préparer le 5 cavalier des deux B5
[Rires]
par contre tes thématique
champion pas non plus
je voulais montrer que la barrière tous
les Blancs jouent avec avec
beaucoup moins intéressant
peut-être mais du coup
3 est très naturel et c'est pour ça que
c'est le couleur le plus joué parce que
empêche donc le plan tour B8 et 5 c'est
plus flexible
en tout cas on sait pourquoi il est là
on sait pourquoi elle est là il veut il
veut créer des choses
est-ce que ton bébé était un coup parce
que bon là sur cavalier de deux ans
n'importe quoi
un B5 et j'ai vu une partie comme ça
alors je sais plus dans quel tournage
j'ai vu mais j'ai vu un truc comme ça
j'ai vu un truc comme ça je sais plus où
j'ai eu mais il y a pas longtemps c'est
une proslig ou un truc comme ça
je sais plus j'ai vu un truc
pour ça aussi
qu'on s'y perd ça fait vraiment
l'enfant qui a rien compris à la
catalogue
alors évidemment vu que c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde qui le joue et
que ça s'apprête pas des idées très
subtiles mais ça fait vraiment ça quoi
tu donnes la case de trois tu as fait bu
ton pion de 4 tu as plus le pion c'est
quatre tu es pas prêt de le récupérer
le cavalurant ces trois dans la Catalane
c'est l'erreur typique en fait si
j'avais un élève qui jouerait comme ça
non mais c'est souvent ça quand
un grand mal je ne conception un peu
originale c'est très profond pour lui et
donc évidemment tu respectes admire même
d'ailleurs tu comprends pas et quand
c'est le les mêmes coups qui sont joués
par un joueur plus débutant sur
des fois en fait et ça c'est important
les meilleurs joueurs du monde en fait
arrivent à trouver une sorte de
d'équilibre entre ce qui est normal et
pas normal parce que c'est vrai qu'on
nous pareil tu vois un élève qui fait
qui fait exactement ce que fait 45 tu
vas pas être content pourtant ça
cartonne qui le fait et champion du
monde enfin
lançons j'en prends du monde donc en
fait c'est le meilleur aujourd'hui
actuellement il y a peut-être même le
meilleur joueur de l'histoire et en fait
bon il y a des raisons et en fait eux
ils savent très bien tout ce qui se
passe il me dit pas que Carlson ne
connaît pas c'est c’était dans la
Catalane c'est impossible
donc en fait il sait très bien mais il y
a des exceptions et lui en fait il sait
où le trouver et il sait quoi faire et
ça je trouve que dans le jeu d'échec
c'est bon on voit aussi que ce qu'on
disait juste avec des mots sur les
explications des coupes bizarres sur la
bizarreté des coups de Magnus et
confirmé par la jauge en fait j'avais
pas fait gaffe mais la jauge pointe déjà
en faveur des Noirs donc
en fait on n'est pas le soir à critiquer
les coups l'ordinateur à faire
profondeur aussi et donc il y a un côté
vraiment probable de Magnus et ça ça
confirme les intentions belliqueuses
dont on parlait juste en voyant la fiche
c'est un petit côté à la Emmanuel
lascare de jouer non pas les meilleurs
coups mais de jouer le bonhomme quoi ok
donc je vais pas essayer de jouer
parfaitement contre toi le cette année
dans une position où je vais me battre
tout simplement
donc c'est
après mûre réflexion déjà un quart
d'heure de réflexion à Nice a joué à 6
et donc ouais c'est vrai que maintenant
que le pion est en 4 et que ça bloque le
fou G2 il y a pas forcément nécessité à
bouger la tour à 8 pour jouer P5 donc
voilà là c'est un vrai Gambie en fait
d'habitude en catalan on parle pas de
Gambie catalan
il a fait
de son frère hier un gus
depuis alpha zéro on joue à quatre dans
toutes les positions
là c'est ouf
alors H4 c'est un coup encore une fois
positionnellement c'est un coup qui a
l'air dégueulasse parce que ben je donne
la casse G4 vous savez que plein de fois
on joue plutôt H3 pour contre la cage de
4 pour pas qu'ils cavale etc H4 c'est un
coup alors écoute et en plus on menace
pas c'est ça c'est ça le truc c'est
souvent quand on peut jouer à H4 à
l'alfa0 c'est pour jouer à chaque mais
là 500 je comprends rien
je ne comprends pas
quel peut être son plan ici parce que la
toi tu penses qu'il a arrêté
en vrai une partie internet je pose la
question mais
non
je comprends je comprends pas c'est ça
ça paraît
je crois que guéri alors est-ce que j'ai
un plan sur la tête de guéri j'en ai un
j'ai un plan
il vient de réfléchir un quart d'heure à
jouer à 6 je peux vous garantir que H4
il n'y a pas pensé quoi j'ai un plan sur
le guerrier
il y a même pas besoin de regarder
l'arbre d'ouverture on doit être dans la
nouveauté
alors problème c'est que il est pas dans
le cadre caméra qui sont pas très très
bien encadrés malheureusement il n'est
pas dans le cadre j'aurais bien aimé
voir sa tête parce que la position en
vrai
[Musique]
le pion qu'il a pris le balcon C4 et le
pion C4 est maintenant entre ses doigts
le fait gigoter un peu à la Boris
galphaand mais sans le talent de Boy
quel est le meilleur joueur au monde
pour pour faire tourner les pions les
pièces
n'est qu'un pas limitateur mais donc là
il se prend H4 et il doit être un peu
comme nous alors sûrement que lui il a
déjà compris l'idée
mais en tout cas ça a dû le surprendre
et l'idée
il attend de voir
la suite logique de A6 le premier coup
qu'on peut regarder c'est c'est B5 quand
même
la diagonale hier c'est pareil c'est une
colonne la colonne blanche là
mais bon le problème c'est que dès que
tu joues dès que tu descends et ben tu
donnes aussi enfin tu m'aides
[Musique]
ou tu veux d'abord
c'est pas il veut jouer la position
je pense que
salut à vous c'est pas que vous allez
bien vous passez un beau dimanche
dans le train
pardon
[Rires]
si vous avez des questions sur ça ça
biographie c'est moi ça me gratte
officiel donc
donc B5 quel coup est-ce qu'il peut
jouer alors je pense que j'ai une idée
tu joues 5 avaler 5 avec le 4 en fait là
on a compris clairement que la case G5
elle est visée parce que à un moment
donné c'est dans cette position ça fait
vraiment plein de blistes tu vois parce
que
[Musique]
ça fait un petit peu ça fait un petit
peu attaque
d'alcoolique si tu veux tu vois que
le 26 mai c'est comme ma sœur
à ta sœur
[Rires]
une attaque à la loi ça enlève le
cavalier de défenseur en M6 ça libère la
carte de 4 ça prend l'espace à la droite
donc ça se marie très bien avec
cache-cadre mais ça se marie pas du tout
avec j'ai trois fougères quoi c'est ça
le problème de ça donc est-ce qu'on peut
juste rester avec les pions en carte des
cartes parce que pour l'instant ils sont
parfaits parfaitement placés c'est pure
il contrôle toutes les cases de la
cinquième rangée avec un importante de
la cinquième rangée ils prennent de
l'espace ça va donc
est-ce qu'on peut juste les garder ici
mais après c'est la question c'est
comment justifier H4
alors attends je vais avoir une idée de
génie
[Rires]
non c'est pas l'idée de génie peut-être
pas
non ça marche pas
ça aurait été l'idée de H3 mais c'est
pas l'idée
je pensais à un truc alors encore une
fois je suis désolé mais j'ai envie de
pousser mon pion
et je pensais même faire un truc comme
ça alors je sais que j'ouvre ton fou
est impossible enfin ça ça très bizarre
que maintenant je mets un cavalier en F4
alors j'essaie de trouver par là mais
ouais vraiment plus j'aime pas du tout
il y a trop de cadre en plus même chez
quatre monstrueusement
Fortus et c'est juste une question
est-ce qu'ils vont mater ou pas mais a
priori non pas avec le point je donne
toute façon
c'est lui le prof dans cette partie
et je vais voir si je peux venir mettre
une personne
c'est un peu plus de sens
le jeu à la dame comme ils peuvent mais
ils ont pas déjà un plan de plus en C4
quoi donc
[Musique]
je suis d'accord
juste
d'accord c'est d'aller prendre un chien
qui a jamais tactique
peut-être ça peut être ça non
et puis là maintenant il fait des cinq
je n'arrive pas à comprendre mais un
truc en fait ce qui se passe
en fait tout est bizarre maintenant
ouais mais c'est quoi
[Musique]
différent
à ces quatre est plus faible mais
[Musique]
si tu bouges le cabine je sais pas ce
que tu fais
en fait il y a tous les coups qui me
disent bien mais
[Musique]
juste H4
idh5 même si ça a l'air très bizarre ça
me rappelle une phrase de Laurent
fascinet à propos d'une position
similaire de
enfin similaire ou Manu savait à jouer à
H4 il m'avait dit juste quand tu dis ah
il faut dire beurre ensuite voilà idée
de H4 en fait on se demande depuis tout
à l'heure c'est peut-être juste de jouer
à 5 alors après si les parents concrètes
marchent quoi parce que évidemment ça a
l'air
ça a l'air très très branlant comme
conception très bancal mais
ouais peut-être baisser un cachet quand
même
en tout cas
quoi ah oui complètement complètement
est-ce qu'on se fait un petit tour des
tables on n'a pas encore vu ce qui se
passe chez Mamed
donc là on a
Fabiano qui joue contre
on va vous mettre la
5e
[Musique]
et mes connaissances théoriques sont là
je suis perdu
bon alors les blancs ils ont les pièces
actives en fait ici les Noirs aussi ce
pion qui est qui est
prêt manger au final si tu manges F7 je
pense que peut-être que tu as peur des
problèmes sur un F2
ou pas
peut-être que il veut juste
[Musique]
en fait peut-être que
je gagne non
à toi en F2
contre deux fois j'attaque là aussi deux
fois donc ça on peut être certain que
les deux joueurs connaissent jusqu'à cet
art quand même oui c'est sûr
comme ça où chaque coup peut être
perdant alors j'aime bien l'idée
d'éventuellement de faire un jour tout
raciste
il la joue dans
dans un grand joueur de camping Budapest
des 4 cavaliers
on voit très souvent cette idée à cinq
thoracis au lycée ensuite parfois même
en G6
alors après c'est quand même un peu
surprenant ici
parce que parce qu'après il y a pas trop
d'autres idées
[Musique]
en fait il doit y avoir un espèce de
soupçon à la loi c'est ça puisque les
noirs n'ont pas jamais pris aussi son PC
de comprendre pourquoi quand même
attention
[Musique]
et si tu joues pas ici ben tu as des
problèmes là voilà tout simplement donc
voilà F français dégueulasse et puis je
pense que j'ai encore une fois
même chose minimum
OK et donc à 5 c'est pas du tout
peut-être juste
j'attaque comme ça qu'elle a quand même
assez violent
cette situation
recette ils prennent leur temps
donc après il faut quand même on
commence à comprendre maintenant
on sait qu'il y a un exemple réciproque
et que ben on va aller manger de temps
que la tour quoi
après ça je pense que ma meilleure offre
il a rien inventé c'est la c'est encore
la théorie donc les gens en fait juste
parce que
à balle dessus ou quoi mais je pense pas
alors vas-y de la meuf 4
F6 F6 a été joué
parce qu'en fait
on imagine thoracis
ça a l'air de faire mal
donc la tour raciste marche pas et F6 ça
empêche ouais si ça on comprend bien F-1
ça empêche fof6
apparemment ici quand même l'ordinateur
est pas content F6 il considère
qu'il y a mieux que que
si vraiment c'est une erreur théorique
un Caravana c'est aussi un des joueurs
les mieux préparés donc
tout à l'heure là j'ai mentionné à ni
guéri c'était Nakamura qui disait à
propos des joueurs les mieux prépare au
monde que pendant quelques années assez
longtemps il a considéré Fabienne comme
le joueur le mieux prépa au monde et que
récemment est considéré que Annie j'ai
peut-être devant mais mes Fabi c'est
clairement des plus gros des plus gros
bosseurs d'ailleurs je me permets de
lire le point de vue de RK
je m'exprime vraiment en spectateur je
me suis pas joueur du tout mais car ça
ne va me dire hors sont vraiment
agréables à regarder les autres ça se
résume à qui veut oublier le premier la
ligne de l'ordi alors il y a de ça mais
ça se résume pas à on oublie aussi quand
on voit deux joueurs du top niveau
réciter 20 coups de théorie et faire nul
droits derrière on se dit bah ouais en
fait on pourrait le faire si on avait la
mémoire si on avait non non il faut pas
voyez que qui sont monstrueux et dans
les positions où ils signent la nulle
ils nous battrait avec les deux couleurs
quoi enfin
ça se résume pas ça du tout pour être là
c'est pas du tout enfin si on les faits
de théorie ils sont ils sont encore les
meilleurs joueurs du monde il y a
vraiment pas que la théorie mais je suis
d'accord qu'il y a des joueurs plus ou
moins théoriques ou qui ont une théorie
plus ou moins différente Magnus il a un
savoir beaucoup plus large il peut un
peu jouer toutes les ouvertures que
certains joueurs qui se spécialisent
comme Maxime par exemple là maintenant
il s'est il s'est diversifié cette deux
dernières années mais pas l'entrée
longtemps il jouait que naydorf que
greenfeld donc il allait en savoir
énormément sur une seule ouverture
mais bon bref donc est-ce que tu as
trouvé un autre couple F6 parce que
c'est embêtant
[Musique]
et peut-être quand même c'est moche
j'ai pas envie
est-ce que est-ce qu'on se fait mater je
sais pas si je fais un coup du style
allez
on comprend donc visiblement c'est la
ligne de l'ordinateur vu que la jauge ne
bouge pas et on comprend que c'était
plus dans ta prépa tu peux pas jouer ça
a l'air horrible donc F6 c'est le coup
vraiment humain maintenant ça montre un
monde un manque de travail de la part de
ma mère sur cette variante en tout cas
voilà donc la même sur ton problème de
ce que tu te fais ma tête ce que je
voulais un demander c'est pas sûr du
tout quoi
mais du coup tu as aucune envie de
rentrer là-dedans parce que tu peux
réfléchir pendant deux heures et elle le
pense
[Musique]
et tu sais que tu fais face à
l'ordinateur
et compliqué non mais c'est clair c'est
tu connais pas la position si tu es un
plus
c'est trop compliqué
cet échec il y a tout rêve 7 contre
échec mais en fait trois chats et la
tour est clouée
mais
oups pardon je voulais pas faire ça
j'avais trois bouches je pense pas mais
bon ça fait peur FC c'est un coup qui
ressemble plus normal parce que ça fait
peur mais d'un autre côté
attention que là il faut être sûr qu'il
arrive à ressortir ta pièce parce que
il peut y avoir juste du H4 H5 selon
l'idée pour
ce pion c'est c'est
une très grosse épine
[Musique]
l'évaluation semble
assez clair sans faveur des blancs
mais bon c'est la bonne idée sur le noir
elle a l'air vraiment moche
donc bizarre ou alors peut-être qu'il a
confondu il y a peut-être
qu'ils connaissait une variante
similaire mais légèrement différente et
puis à pied c'était le bon coup et en
revanche perdait et puis
[Musique]
après ça reste compliqué là il faut
trouver une défense quand même pour le
pion
en deux couches je te mange hein
en fait sur ça ben je fais juste ça je
pense
et je te dis bah vas-y je sais si
tu passes plus
et quand tu manges là il y a des cloches
de partout donc c'est pas l'air très
agréable et toute fin les fous sont trop
ouverts
[Musique]
malheureusement malheureusement ça
dépend comme ça mais c'est pas loin
t'imagines si je et là j'ai un peu
de moi encore en plus
on n'a pas vu les autres alors allez
le français puis les enfants
[Musique]
et il a fait une grande Feld
à copier le répertoire de
médecine
donc il y a plein dedans pour jouer il y
a pas mal de ventes de nuls aussi donc
ils sont extrêmement étudiés qui vont
très très loin
c'est pas à quel point
c'est rare pour firou mais c'est avant
tout un genre de cela
donc
des grandes variantes de la
moi je suis pas du tout un expert de la
de la bonne fête
quand même dire des généralités
en finale le pion passé éloigné mais au
final avait vraiment très peu de pièces
le pion passé éloigné des Noirs peut
leur donner un avantage en finale de roi
c'est juste gagnant
mais tant qu'il y a des pièces sur
l'échiquier le centre et la possibilité
de créer un pion passé sur la colonne
des avec des seins que 5 de 6
favorise globalement les blancs alors
après il faut pousser ses pions avec
précaution parce que dès qu'on pousse un
pion ça donne des cas si on pose des 5
dans la case de 5 par exemple etc donc
après un autre facteur c'est quand même
la tour C7 qui qui peut être un peu
bizarrement placé quand même
c'est quand j'ai pu en A7 B6 et que je
veux contrôler surtout la casse 4
mettre d'ailleurs même souvent en
cavalence
mais ici non ça va pas de sens mais toi
je pense parce que je risque de perdre
ça
est-ce que est-ce que ton B2 est un coup
et en plus je bouge mon four il y a du
caval-eve donc ça a l'air
du coup
donc sinon c'est un peu le coup
automatique mais si on se rend compte
que
dans l'air on va on va réfléchir un peu
à ce con parce que c'est très concret
c'est
lui il joue pour le garde dans toutes
les positions
donc c'est pas du tout une question
débile c'est au contraire c'est une très
bonne question
juste ça marche pas mais en fait c'est
toujours 50 quand on regarde les coups
candidats c'est normal de calculer des
variantes de passer du temps qui marche
pas du tout
un procès d'élimination dans
la recherche du bon coup donc faut
prendre F3 il y a des positions où ça
ira très bien position similaire mais
légèrement différente ce sera le
meilleur coup donc il faut calculer faut
prendre
bref il a dû calculer tour B2 et
finalement il s'est résolu à jouer le
coup plus
solide que tourbé 2 tours ça évite donc
un argument pour reprendre du fou c'est
garder la tour
en baie vitrée où elle peut aller en B2
mais te reprends à l'air un peu plus
naturel mais un argument pour faut
prendre
il n'est pas obligé de reprendre un
tempo d'ailleurs c'est c'est pas ce
qu'il fait il réfléchit
de garder la pièce développée évidemment
mais faut prendre c'est pas totalement
alors H3 et maintenant la question se
pose encore mais je crois que c'est
encore la même réponse tout le temps
j'attaque là-haut et en plus donc c'est
un coup hyper hyper joli ok donc c'est
quand même généralement ce fou on va on
l'échange très souvent dans le projet et
est-ce qu'un coup comme le 5 c'est une
possibilité
[Musique]
pour jouer contre celui-là et ouvrir
c'est quand même très
prometteant quoi
[Musique]
c'est concret
euse
ça peut être une idée en tout cas
où le pion ah il se met à courir vite
avec le fou G7 qui contrôle la case de
promotion
qui paye pas de mine pour l'instant il
est isolé et tout ça il est sur la
caisse de départ
il peut s'avérer sprinter c'est assez
vite
et donc à priori on prend mais c'est
peut-être plus par habitude que par
nécessité
c'est le fou qui fait un peu défaut on
va le manger après s'il a une meilleure
idée je veux bien
ça encore une fois un dessin
prendre l'air très naturel
le
en fait essayer de tuer lui le fouet
alors
je sais pas à quel point
je peux aussi prendre
et même
j'imagine une cavaliers
[Rires]
ça mange du mal à croire que je vais la
perdre après
cela
[Musique]
oui oui j'ai pas grand chose
alors allons voir les enfants peut-être
allez alors les enfants on va faire
l'ordre
bon ça c'est une Espagnole assez
standard j'ai envie de dire ok un
cabanon de 7 c'est bizarre en fait
pour éviter la pétrole
parce qu'en fait ici souvent ouais
quand même mais pourquoi il met pas le
cavalier en CS non en fait c'est
considéré comme le meilleur coup alors
c'est pas on peut jouer qu'à la saisie
évidemment mais
puis on sait si c'est un peu la punition
de cet ordre de ça autorise à transposer
dans une vraie italienne donc ça charge
pas à punir les blancs mais pourquoi
tout le monde ne joue pas d'abord fusée
4 puis de trois puis seulement peut-être
cavalier F3 par contre dans l'italienne
parce que il y a ces 6 ici le cavalier
est souvent mal placé dans celle-ci dans
l'italienne parce que les blancs vont
jouer puis on sait trois et qui contrôle
la case des cartes la classe B4 elle
cavalier je retrouve pas terrible et
donc là on joue celle-ci aussi
pour pouvoir jouer des cinq et punir le
placement à peu près cosse du foin donc
c'est un peu la ligne test de la
variante il faut s'éclate au deuxième
coup quoi
voilà
et dans la ligne théorique je crois que
c'est faux
[Musique]
comment ça marche
et il y a une ligne avec des deux
faut prendre alors je sais pas si c'est
maintenant comment ça marche à
3 je gagne pas comment ça marche je me
souviens plus
il me semble que oui
il y a une partie très connue de je peux
c'était la Coupe du monde entre Wailly
et Ding
avec un circuit de dames je sais pas si
tu connais
c'est un truc de ce style là
et
[Musique]
plutôt ça se passe
sur C3
ah non je crois que la prise en 4 elle
est pas bonne c'est fou bref maintenant
à cause de ça ça et là on joue les deux
et tu prends tu cavalier prends je crois
et là il y a une ligne marrante je crois
que c'est pris ce cavalier G5
petit rock
ça marche mais il y a une ligne avec un
bref mais c'est intéressant
et sur sur A5 alors moi dans ma dans mes
lignes je dévoile un truc et bon moi
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait jouer A4 et
pas à 3 parce que dans cette position là
et ben des fois
ok
tu peux récupérer un truc comme ça tu as
souvent un akatura 5 qui est assez
thématique à sa position
et
je sais que bon un peu plus de 5 le
ventre que j'avais vu la vente avec on a
on a vu un instant
donc à trois ok donc là c'est pas
possible
et c'est une sorte de flipper qui nous
fait tard
ienne ou justement il n'y a pas le
mauvais cavalier en sais c'est quoi
donc
en tout cas c'est une position
évidemment qui ressemble à bien d'autres
ouvertures italiennes filières et tout
donc c'est une position
où les joueurs sont dépourvus de plan et
tout mais c'est une position nouvelle il
y a très vite plus de théorie et on joue
aux échecs et je crois que c'est
exactement ce que veut Carole Nakamura
face aux petits poussins du
tournoi
qui est censé enfin quel genre le moins
bien classé et donc le joueur abattre
absolument pour qui joue la gagne donc
sa petite ligne il a une position mais
il sait qu'il a pas aucun avantage c'est
pas du tout ce qu'il veut il veut juste
jouer aux échecs éviter un combat
théorique
et
espérer gagner sur sur sa force quoi
une autre mais bon après Ariane doit pas
être mécontent d'avoir déjà égalisé quoi
non c'est clair c'est clair
et donc dans la partie c'est la partie
moi qui m'intéresse beaucoup et c'est
Google
qui sont beaucoup joué aussi avec
ok c'est 6 E3
donc
[Musique]
Gérard qui a joué G4 dans plein de
positions similaires bah quand la file
d'or par exemple
il assiette de réfuter ta fameuse filée
de archerie en juin G4 avec la même
genre d'idée tu donnes le pion mais ça
tenue quand même en plus et c'est lui
qui l'a qui l'a joué pour la première
fois ici et c'est devenu une des très
grandes lignes de la semislam
ique
on peut montrer H3 cavalier abscisse
foug2 il y a de la dame
[Musique]
et tu me dis que tu as un plan passé
c'est ça
je
suis pas sûr de tout
[Musique]
non je peux pas
j'ai l'impression que ça peut être que
mieux pour les blancs tout ça mais bon
après elle en est déjà très loin dans un
truc qui s'est pas c'est pas joué donc
pourquoi
4 h 5
il y a plus le problème en H3 tes
pensées
bon en tout cas les joueurs qui sont
bien préparé
et on peut imaginer faut prendre ces
quatre du coup ou pas
où est-ce qu'on joue pas
regarder parce que maintenant qu'on a
récupéré le pion il y a même des cas on
peut changer de dames quoi
mais bon priori c'est pas le plan des
blancs d'échanger
[Musique]
tu vas attaquer tu veux garder la dame
tu vas pas faire ça par exemple
c'est pas forcément l'idéal
toujours pas pris même une fois qu'il
est pris c'est on veut pas changer d'âme
tout de suite mais on pourra le faire au
moins
ceci n'est pas pris il y a un cas où on
le voit plus
même si c'est difficile parce que quand
le roi au centre et je sais pas où
est-ce que je vais mettre mon roi dans
le futur et ben ça
me change
pour libérer la case 4 et après fixer la
case de 6 la case à 6
c'est peut-être plus ambitieux mais
bon c'est tellement concret c'est
marrant
en tout cas ouais
E5 pas bon donc il faut prendre ces
quatre
et si je mange là
[Musique]
mais
est-ce que j'ai pas du thème même si ce
n'est pas une fourchette
[Musique]
trop gourmand mais bon après
mais dès qu'elle bouge mon cou c'est un
grand rock quoi
mais j'ai du mal à la virer
j'arrive pas à la chasser j'arrive pas à
manger lui tranquillement et je pense
que
il y a déjà un peu plus sur les Noirs
il y a ça à regarder quoi
donc il faut être précis parce que
je serais persuadé d'être très bien avec
le blanc
oui non mais je comprends en tout cas là
on prend les blancs plutôt que les Noirs
les Noirs c'est très dur si tu as pas de
développement tu arrives pas ok mais les
Noirs ont le matériel contre l'activité
donc entre le cadet et le benjamin se
tournoi donc gokuge 17 ans à 17h à 18
ans et c'est déjà 22 de tout meilleur
joueur du monde
ils vont pas s'arrêter là et ça peut
mettre la pression aussi sur des gens
qui sont déjà vieux comme notre alliésa
il va fêter ses 20 ans je crois c'est le
18 juin qu'il est né
je crois qu'il a 19 ans
[Musique]
on parie juste sur le résultat de la
marque classique
par si tu veux Magnus
alors vas-y je t'écoute
je comprends pas
[Musique]
mais j'avais envie de mettre guéri mais
je suis le stade quand même
[Rires]
[Musique]
la nuit et puis ça m'aide pas trop tout
ça
alors Caravana
[Musique]
il a pas joué fou de 5 il a pas compris
son idée de photos
et là attention qui peut se passer des
choses très très très très très vilaines
ok moi j'ai mis à zéro aussi
alors
pardon donc ce contretempire rouge
je pense que
mais bon il y a un monde où le pion a
fait
et puis il va tout faire pour le prendre
nul mais
il peut courir très très vite ce pion
avec le Fougerat qui contrôle la caserne
peut battre enfin
j'avoue que
je suis plus du tout ce que j'ai pu être
un peu il y a une quinzaine d'années
mais
bon le Petit Poucet qui bat
qui banaka ça peut être marrant quoi
et gagner à la fin non je pense qu'il va
faire
[Musique]
aux Olympiades
après un prix de beauté de
Google
[Musique]
c'est une partie qui marque
mon but vu que je te laisse parier sur
Google parce que parce que tu as pas
[Musique]
je vais parier sur abdos
ce qui n'est pas mauvais choix
d'ailleurs
il peut se passer tout et n'importe quoi
mais j'avoue que bravo tu as mis quand
même 4 victoires décisive
de développement
je sais pas trop comment on place les
pièces
en fait il y a les trois cases sont pas
totalement idiotes
plus agressif sur garder la diagonale
a2f7
bon fou de 3 c'est peut-être le coup que
j'aime le moins mais faut deux il y a un
argument ça couvre bien le roi et ça
contrôle la façade
mais
non
c'est ce qu'on joue des 7 ou est-ce
qu'on joue dans F6 est-ce qu'on va
manger pardon est-ce qu'on va manger ce
pion
où est-ce qu'on joue des sept grand rock
on se dit bah tiens on va mettre le roi
en sécurité
[Musique]
les blancs peuvent être contents quoi et
cela si tu fais grand rat à 5 à 6
ça va très vite quoi
pas envie de jouer avec un cavalier
après champion de plus mais c'est vrai
que le roi il fait il fait en plus
vis-à-vis
j'ai dû cavalier ça donne pas trop envie
de jouer ça il y a pas encore de plus
hein
[Musique]
j'ai cru que tu disais ça
[Rires]
non c'est vrai que ça c'est intéressant
ce que tu dis à 4h10 et j'ai pas envie
de
assez logique mais
à qui est-ce que ça favorise
en tout cas c'est une position hyper
compliqué franchement
mais bon ok c'est
[Musique]
avoir du mal à le faire le rappelant
c'est illégal jusqu'à nouvel ordre et le
roi noir comme on l'a vu dans la
variante il faut laisser 7 à 4 grands
rock à 5 et pas certain qu'il soit plus
en sécurité en C8 que en plein centre de
l'échiquier donc
[Musique]
ouais c'est chaud
Abdou
bah écoutez moi si vous voulez gagner
plein de points de chaîne et ben je vous
je vous envoie tous vers vous cache vous
savez qui est noir en tout cas je vous
recommande je vous pousse un petit peu à
parier pour Google
généralement c'est c'est un bon paré
et en cas de nul vous serez pas débité
simplement on voit que ça parait sec sur
Abdou pas confiance on se touche
après ça dépend si vous voulez gagner ou
pas si vous voulez gagner c'est Google
ici c'est déjà pas bien quoi pour les
blancs
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
points chênes
sur mon compte en banque cette somme
mais malheureusement non ça c'est ces
chaînes sur tscom c'est les pointes
tu refuses
[Musique]
un petit peu quand même
sur abdos du coup ça c'est quand même
beaucoup ça fait un peu
c'est très rare que ça soit légal de
parier sur des tournois d'échec même de
ce niveau en général c'est champion du
monde oui mais sinon c'est à peu près
tout je vous entends où on pouvait
parier sur tout je sais pas si tu as
connu même la Bundesliga par exemple
première division par équipe d'Allemagne
on pouvait parier sur tous les
échiquiers et du coup tous les échiquets
de Bundesliga alors c'est fort la mouna
Sega mais c'est au dernier ta DMI quoi
donc le MI qui peut parier sur lui-même
enfin qui peuvent dire à cette patte de
parier sur lui-même ou les nul arrange
aux échec enfin
autoriser des joueurs d'échec à parier
moi je joue moi demain je joue contre un
Non classé
dernière table bah la côte elle est
combien pour mon adversaire
moi je vais faire parfait
merci
je suis allé sur sur mon adversaire
il y a des enquêtes quand même
mais il y a tellement
de
la ranger depuis depuis des années
quand tu le sais même si tu te propose
une cote en 4e ridicule bah tu peux tu
peux miser ta maison dessus c'est écrit
quoi donc il y a tellement
tellement
[Musique]
c'est pas possible d'autoriser les paris
sur sur des parties
déjà au top niveau c'est dangereux mais
entre amateur
oui puis en plus il est il est assez
petit tout le monde se connaît et il y a
des arrangements et de la triche en fait
qui est trop trop Bader c'est c'est
tu vois enfin
après cela dit c'est plus contre les
paris que contre le déchets parce que au
Tennis
Pro il me disait mais il y a tellement
de trucs mais tu peux parier sur qui va
gagner telle balle etc attends que il y
a plein de triche
juste pour les paris quoi
en attendant est-ce qu'on irait partout
on est on fait un petit tour et puis là
sont H4 H6
il est reparti sur
H40
donc il a surpris la surprise avec lui
deux heures un chaos avec seulement 10
secondes par quoi à partir de 40e c'est
du 2h ko quoi
assez rapide assez violent quand on est
habitué à avoir un rajout une demi-heure
ou 40e etc
donc une position très complexe ou
Magnus à volontairement choisi à cette
ligne tout en sachant que l'ordinateur
donne un petit avantage en noir mais
donc il annonce à son anniversaire je
sais que tu es censé être mieux de ne
pas le théorique mais je vais te la
coller
tu as tellement de possibilités avec les
noirs et moi j'ai des trucs bon j'ai dû
à 5 qui avait le 4 j'ai du dessin et
même là regarde bah il y a un vis-à-vis
comment je le fais je parle ça c'est
moche pour celles et ceux qui reprendrai
en route mieux ça a joué une catalane et
il a donné le pion Seclin elle a pas
cherché à le récupérer plutôt que de
donner c'est tout à fait standard et au
lieu de le récupérer il a joué des coûts
qu'on considère habituellement mauvais
qui avaler ces trois et le 4 mauvais bah
pourquoi parce que le pion C4 comme vous
voyez maintenant les défis
définitivement perdu et
c'est pas seulement que c'est un pion
c'est que ce pion par contre la case de
3 affaibli par la brousse 4 on en
parlait du cavalier B4 cavalier tout à
l'heure en cas de dessin des blancs puis
on prend des Cinq puis on prend un
dessin rafwe F5 aussi il faut les trois
enfin cinq questions
donc c'est une conception très originale
et
alors après visuellement déjà ne
serait-ce que visuellement le centre des
blancs semble donner une compensation
suffisante mais attention c'est si
personne ne joue comme ça avec les
Blancs alors peut-être que les gens vont
se mettre à jouer après cette partie
mais si personne ne joue comme ça avec
les Blancs c'est que c'est pas censé
être bon en fait
l'inclusion h4h
bon peu donner des chances d'attaque à
la loi mais pour l'instant on voit pas
trop quand même donc
on va voir quel est le plan de Magnus là
il a joué de quoi c'est logique bon HS
pas forcément nécessaire peut-être même
pas si simple à expliquer il voulait il
voulait sur H5 pouvoir jouer à un code
de l'homme on avait des prix c'était
peut-être dangereux
pour les Noirs si
c'était développé sans faire à schisme
mais du coup au moins sur H1 que là ils
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent quoi
un peu bizarre de jouer à chier avant
que les Blancs ne sachent et là tout à
l'heure
si je fais à 3 d'abord pour essayer de
faire des cinq là maintenant je te le
donne une super carte en B3 pour un
cavalier et c'est terrible
enfin mais oui en fait c'est pas simple
de prendre des décisions
c'est pas en lien avec un plan quoi
en tout cas c'est les positions
intéressantes j'aime bien parce que tu
vois les Noirs ont un pion de plus mais
c'est vrai que les trucs concrets à
avoir et
peut-être une idée j'ai une idée alors
si c'est ça je serai très contente parce
que c'est potentiellement ridicule mais
bon je vais tenter n'a pas peur du
ridicule tu sais
je vais t'expliquer mon raisonnement et
après on va voir à quel point c'est le
grotes
et puis moi certes mais maintenant avec
toutes les colonnes il y a clairement du
jeu
d'ailleurs dans les positions
[Musique]
c'est relou parce que la case des trois
comme on l'a expliqué et si le pion de
plus il est arriéré en C7 et que j'ai
deux colonnes au vert c'est pas du tout
la même donc c'est peut-être un coup
malin alors six mois je tourne
alors si je joue un coup bah je vais
prendre un tiroir fuite mais bon c'est
juste pour pour voir un peu ton truc
sur ça si je joue cavalière 5 tu veux
jouer comment en fait parce que ok j'ai
compris que là tu peux me faire ça
mais si je fais cavaler à 5 maintenant
l'idée reprend du cavalier et d'avoir
une structure saine qu'est-ce que tu
veux j'ai le droit de la prise aussi et
tu prends du piano
[Musique]
E
parce que il y a
est-ce que dessin qui était un coup
aussi enfin bon
[Musique]
de voir comment les joueurs ils vont ils
vont jouer leur coup parce que là on
sait pas s'il faut jouer avec P3 s'il
faut jouer pour E5 ou pour du dessin ou
si un cavalier 5 maintenant ça pend ça a
l'air pas très bon cavaluation parce que
ça ferme tous les fous après des
échanges tu vois je
j'ai l'impression que ça se passe pas
bien et là je fais F4 qui est naturel
[Musique]
je sortir une pièce pour sortir une
pièce c'est rare à ce niveau en général
c'est tout sur une pièce en lien avec un
plan plus global et là je vois pas trop
l'idée parce que
par exemple j'en ai crois pas
[Musique]
donc
je sais pas il faut F4 bon c'est sûr
qu'il est mieux cancer mais ça a l'air
un peu vite quand même comme diagonale
F4 f4c
une grosse partie entre
les deux rivaux
alors partie suivante
ça c'est pas une très belle pollution en
fait
là pour les pour les noirs
[Musique]
et là il a ripé il voulait manger aussi
il a fait tourner 6 et donc on disait
peut-être ici fou dessin alors
maintenant il a fait de ces 6
ça marche pas alors on va regarder
c'est prendre des cinq non
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que ça marche
parce que c'est ça l'idée donc si elle
est pas bonne
fou
mais je fais dames
tu prends du pur en dessin la même
variante mais avec puis on prend des
cinq pas
[Musique]
pardon
avec les Blancs
[Musique]
salut copain un peu aujourd'hui je vais
faire un tournoi d'échec figurez-vous je
me suis levé
tôt ce matin très très l'aube pour aller
jouer à
sabia ça s'appelle c'est une heure et
demie de chez moi
et je vais faire un bon tournoi j'ai
failli perdre la route 1 et la ronde 2
[Rires]
qui a un prénom espagnol
et bon et la ronde 2 j'ai donné deux
pions en deux coups mais mais un truc de
fou je veux un 1800 et j'avais une dame
j'ai un pion en C6 évidemment
moi j'ai bougé madame il fait carrément
mais
bon après ça va j'ai réussi quand même
gagner non mais je souhaitais pas du
tout je soussignais pas du tout je juste
je voyais pas et dernière et après j'ai
hyper bien joué j'ai
battu deux amis
et un et un CM que je crois que tu aimes
beaucoup tu as beaucoup de respect
et donc non c'était très propre les
trois parties là et dans la partie j'ai
joué un 2350 on a fait nul et donc j'ai
fini à 6000 sur 7 je suis arrivé premier
execo mais deuxième au départage donc
c'était bien ouais mais j'ai fait
d'ailleurs à fracton enfin j'ai battu un
DMI j'ai trouvé une très belle tactique
en finale et c'est le thème c'est la
percée
[Musique]
et franchement en plus je suis content
parce que j'ai grind c'est un ami mais
il est un peu vieux enfin le MI il a il
a pas encore réveillé
il m'a juste thème de Londres et
il a rien fait il attendait enfin
c'était horrible et j'ai joué j'ai enfin
j'ai essayé essayé j'ai essayé essayer
et j'ai plutôt bien graine je suis assez
content de la partie franchement
et et la tactique finale était très
jolie très jolie on avait plus trop de
temps en plus tous les deux c'était très
joli après s'il y a une petite pause en
cage je veux voir si je peux la mettre
la position quoi la position c'est
facile à voir mais c'est très joli
c'est très joli
sinon
l'idée j'aurais voulu j'ai vu ça
on va on va on va voilà mais fous prends
ici et normal et surtout prendre bon on
va bouger la dame je crois et on va
aller
c'est la partie
gagne le plus réussi et la partie après
un blocus ma tour et monter mon roi mais
c'est pas sûr encore
[Musique]
et donc
pour le mal depuis longtemps sinon la
structure est mauvaise la dame et puis
le pur et 6 il est très fort tant qu'il
y ait mais il peut être perdu au final
donc
je peux pas manger à trois je crois
j'ai l'impression que ça marche pas trop
genre de choses
maintenant et maintenant on va prendre
je vais la découverte
et je n'aurai pas la même flûte
attention pas se tromper ça a l'air dans
ma tête mais il y a une dame qui est
très très loin qui va revenir ici
et par contre j'ai quand même moi j'ai
peut-être qui doit gagner en sortant
j'ai maths
intermédiaire du style d'amitié
je le dis pas
je pense que
[Musique]
la dernière fois le roi est trop faible
donc je peux pas manger le pion à
trois-5 fois ou même ramener la tour
aussi qui peut être des idées qui sont
un petit coup de fraise dame G7
ok je pense que je vais bouger ma dame
j'ai pas envie de changer exception
passé je préfère garder mes pièces je
regardais un truc de style de la marche
mais bon
même dommage 4 j'ai 5 et pas si débile
peut-être
bêtement en fait je prends tout le temps
je pense pas que ce soit dramatique mais
je pense que c'est l'idée
comme ça
c'est pas très beau
tu risques de perdre ton pion sur le
long terme faire un pas attention bon
c'est chaud ça reste chaud en tout cas
est-ce qu'on peut voir entre amis firou
ici qui a qui a les Noirs contre
Wesley Sow parti
un petit peu des cinq et maintenant
cavaler le 5
G5 voilà le réflexe c'est un peu de sa
faute
mais faut deux peut-être que ça embêté
le contrôle aussi de la position
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs peut-être
que ici soit jouer à directement fou gs5
à 100 moules on s'en fout pour attaquer
le pion et
dans la MD empêcher aussi parce que ben
je perds la tour en D8
donc intéressant
ce combat majorité centrale contre pions
déjà passé
pour les Noirs
c'est pas
juste si les Noirs joue bêtement qu'elle
est proche
et un coup comme
je sais pas
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas si je pense que
l'échange est un peu mis dedans pour
l'instant parce que plus défendre ce
problème
est avantageuse pour les blancs mais là
il peut y avoir des problèmes sur la 8e
rangée mais
bon en fait les Noirs ont déjà un plan
passé quoi
mais la majorité centrale
faite les blancs sont mieux
elles sont pas moins bien ça c'est sûr
donc là maintenant
mais
[Musique]
non c'est pas ça attends
c'est quoi
[Musique]
très tôt à mon tournoi et je suis rentré
juste pour le temps pour le crime pas le
temps d'en occuper aujourd'hui j'adore
tout le temps
ça sentait pas le coup de génie mais en
fait là il y a un monde où il y a faut
deux puis un pot droit et puis un moment
on chasse la cavalier les cavaliers il a
besoin de d'une casse table et là il en
a pas quoi
mais après avec quelqu'un fermé enfin
attention ce genre de chose ça aussi
[Musique]
et un petit coupage
ça mange pas de pain ça permet d'avoir
une case de fuite aussi
de faire aussi rapidement peut-être
pronostic de nul en tout cas oui oui vu
l'ouverture c'est vrai qu'en fait à ce
niveau là la pollution je pense pas que
que
mais bon l'informatique juste un des
fois
je me sens mieux
un gain de Naka en cette partie mais en
passant par la casse foutue j'ai même
été très précise dans mon pronostic
il va se retrouver foutu
à chaque fois mon adversaire tu sais ma
journée je vais défiler d'or justement
[Musique]
à penser à cavalière
et
puis maintenant on va voir
il y a eu un coup de jouer j'ai vu
il a pris F5 qui est aussi un côté
magique dans beaucoup de position
de la part de fou c'est un peu
j'aurais fait dame prendre oui oui
des fois il y a plein de cas quand
tu as le centre et les pièces blanches
jouent plus en fait donc généralement
une pièce qu'on fait ça si c'est
possible en fait il y a un petit truc
c'est la même position s'il y a pas les
pions de 3 et de 6 on va faire
parce que il y a pas de 5 et du coup on
a accès à la caisse de 4 pour nos pièces
donc là puis on prend F5 c'est très
logique pour donner la carte de carte
c'est juste très mauvais
[Musique]
je suis pas là
comment je continue là-dessus cette
pause
[Musique]
ainsi je veux rester dans mon dans mon
idée alors j'ai 6 alors c'est un coup
qu'il faut faire attention quand on fait
j'insiste il y a des il y a des fois il
y a des thèmes de clouage j'essaie aussi
tu as pas encore fougé 5
ça va ça me choque pas totalement
[Musique]
grave que d'habitude de jouer G6 qui va
falloir vu qu'on a encore le four même
s'il n'est pas le droit j'entends bien
mais
c'est pas c'est pas ça par exemple je
pense que c'est même pas si grave
ça a l'air encore OK
roi de 7 à 20h
faire ça j'ai déjà assez et puis en fait
ta position elle a l'air quand même
assez assez ok pour moi
alors après ça reste paire de fou pour
les blancs et la structure alors elle
est un peu fixée grâce à un caca des
Noirs mais
donc les blancs vont avoir un peu plus
de mal que d'habitude pour faire la
position mais c'est le genre de position
la cas il va pas faire du tout de suite
d'ailleurs enfin du coup il fait pas
fouger 5 non plus il va il va je vais
plutôt C3 mais ok donc faut prendre 5
c'est bon je comprends moi j'expliquais
à quel point je suis terrifié quand je
vois un câble 5 c'est très probablement
ce que j'aurais fait mais j'aurais
sûrement fait en sachant que c'est pas
le meilleur coup tu vois très souvent on
voit l'ordinateur qui de toute façon de
l'ordinateur il se prend jamais de
tactique
qui fait qui me terrifie il s'en fout
Roy royalement
mais en plus
mais en plus parce que de toute façon il
va jamais se prendre une tactique il
s'en fiche donc tel qu'elle arrive 5 il
défend tactiquement mais humainement
surtout face à un joueur comme Dakar tu
as trop peur parce qu'il y a tellement
de thèmes de dames je crois qu'il
menacent pas de cavalier sacrifice de
fois je sais pas quoi enfin c'est à
chaque coup il faut il faut être aux
aguets de attends est-ce que je peux me
faire mater de manière forcément ou pas
et du coup tu joues fous et tu dis bon
tant pis c'est pas le meilleur coup mais
ça reste très solide et
ça va
voilà
la partie de Google
c'est tellement complexe alors au moins
les apprenants
[Musique]
on va dire
sinon si on doit proposer d'autres
couples à 4
mais juste cette position parce que
certes le roi blanc il est un peu mal
placé il y a un vis-à-vis ici il y a un
pion assez c'est une belle épine mais tu
as poussé un pion ah c'était peut-être
l'endroit où tu veux être caché ton roi
tu es pas sûr d'ailleurs de pouvoir un
jour le faire là j'ai cavalé C7 suivi de
peut-être cavalier E8
qui cherche la tour et après cavalier F6
ou cavalier D6 je peux revenir sur des
cases intéressantes assez rapidement
parce que je gagne un temps sur la tour
ici
et bon je comprends que moi il est pas
génial mais le tien non plus est
peut-être que un jour même regarde même
ton G8 comment ça se regardait et puis
c'est moi qui va attaquer sur la colonne
donc est-ce que à 4 à 5 ce serait pas
aussi un peut-être un peu tout moche ou
est-ce que vraiment
je sais pas trop si un jour tu pourras
me manger ou quoi mais je te dis juste
moi je Roque et est-ce que vraiment
c'est intéressant de jouer ça ou pas
parce que
une autre idée radicalement différente
même peut-être A4 ici
je crois que je peux jouer 500 et est-ce
que j'ai pas
comment ça marche
[Musique]
de tout à l'heure tu vois
à la place de la carte c'est de jouer
pour faire tourner
par contre attention les gens ça c'est
uniquement un coup joué par les
spécialistes roi le 2
pause à l'analyse
[Musique]
et à droite
il y a pas il y a plein de trucs
évidemment
[Musique]
mais bon comme j'attaque j'étale le
centre les pièces noires sont français
pasives
en pratique il faut le jouer on a on a
un peu peur on se dit bon
surtout quand on équipe tu regardes ton
capitaine
[Musique]
[Rires]
donc
[Musique]
c'est un coup en tout cas à envisager
mais bon
[Musique]
avec toi
c'est vrai que c'est pas mal quand même
on peut aussi cumuler les deux grands
rock à 5 et là je te joue pas je garde
le pion à 5 je te jure de maintenant
dans ce cas là j'ai quand même le temps
alors dans celle-là je suis pas sûr par
contre le chat je suis désolé
et quand je mange le 4 tu as plus tourné
un et là je pense que ça pose problème
donc peut-être que ça va pas
peut-être que mais après
c'est très chaud donc avec qui ressort
mais il va pas très loin
c'est trop simple d'ailleurs
je suis conscient que c'est bizarre mais
d'un autre côté je
un petit peu
[Rires]
mais bon on voit un peu les idées de ce
qui se passe mais c'est vrai que ouais
si le roi il y a un E2 qui a plus la
tour ici et ben là il y a un monde où
des fois je peux même manger là
donc bon
si j'ai les deux tours ma fiche de faire
trois à la steinte et tout va bien
ce sera tellement extraordinaire
donc là je pense que Google doit hésiter
entre le les deux coups hein
et je vois pas d'autres coups à part ces
deux couleurs parce que on a déjà vu que
c'est très dangereux en tout cas
la moins complexe peut-être celle de
Fiero mais vu que c'est fierou ça peut
quand même
durer
ça peut se liquider et faire mieux tout
de suite il y a un monde où ça dure et
sinon toutes les autres c'est ultra
complexe
parties en perspective pour ce dimanche
pas de repos dominical pour pour les
joueurs
tiens d'ailleurs ma venue
il a joué là un truc tout à l'heure tu
voulais pas mais bon maintenant ça a la
position a changé effectivement il y a
eu cet échange en dessin
il est maintenant enfermé mais avec
c'est vrai que après le coup j'ai H6
jouet on peut imaginer plus tard même
des idées à base de peut-être même j'ai
4g5 ou Dame des deux cavaillage 2
cavalier G4 et on retrouve un petit peu
le schéma indien on avait dit à
takastingen qui est assez courant tout
ça sauf que là on a un pion de moins
pour tout ça et après c'est pas
totalement la même parce que maintenant
après on fera les simples fouilles très
mal placé en bassin
non seulement il est sur le boucher mais
en plus il contrôle pas la loi pain en
F5 ça serait de la case de rêve parce
que après regardez sur F5 et là toutes
les cases intéressantes des trois quatre
et puis en plus ils gêne l'attaque
blanche à la loi donc c'est peut-être
malin et mais je me demandais à tout à
l'heure de me prendre cinq ça se
regardait pas là peut-être que ça se
regarde il y a même des idées tu vois si
tu fais un coup de cavalier il peut y
avoir d'un projet de eh oui et oui
et là c'est dur
donc découverte qui découvre qui et qui
découvre quoi c'est là qu'on va arriver
avec un petit coup droit
après il fait quoi
mais bon bref
c'est très malin parce que parce que
tout à l'heure alors c'était vraiment
dégueulasse quand le Fou est un C8 et là
ça a l'air
est-ce que j'ai 4 c'est un coup
sérieusement
une réponse sérieuse
je veux juste
[Musique]
ok
qui va en découverte attaquer et manger
la dame
donc je peux pas courir pour l'instant
c'est pour ça que je voulais rester en
standard et te dire
on s'en fiche quoi c'est tellement
passif que
on s'en fiche
pas et toi à un moment donné il faudra
que tu trouves que tu prennes une
décision parce que après le problème
c'est que c'est quand même très lent
parce que là sur G5 il y a encore à 5
donc si tu dois faire H1 d'abord j'ai 58
quand même imaginons tu fais un coup je
sens qu'un chat
après je sais pas ça suffit parce que
ma position allait longue à mettre en
place mais
c'est une menace
je sais pas si pour manger ou pas
la meilleure idée du monde
par rapport à la menace en fait mais
et surtout depuis depuis 5
et une concession quand même de
positionnel les pions sont mieux côte à
côte elle contrôle toutes les cases là
ça donne la case de 5 ça rend le pion de
4 arrières sur la colonne ouverte donc
c'est E5 c'est vraiment une grosse
conception mais sa chasse aux cavalier
de FC ça prend l'espace à la loi ça
divise l'échiquier en deux on voit que
là les pièces noires ont du mal à
switcher à la loi et donc E5 c'est
vraiment annoncé à ton adversaire mais
comme il l'avait déjà dit mais là lui
répète je veux te mater
je veux te
mais il va falloir mater parce que si on
m'a pas on a un point de moins il en C4
il va bientôt b4c3 ça peut arriver très
vite le pion de 4 a rien sur la colle
ouverte
les pièces noires ont des bonnes cases
la case de 3 à la case D5 etc donc en
fait positionnellement même mieux c'est
totalement foutu là c'est une question
est-ce qu'il va réussir à mater ou pas
voilà
mais
donc ça c'était d'un point de 5 et puis
on prend des cinq
blanches qui sont aussi ouvertes
[Musique]
on aimait pas du tout cette position
pour les plans avec le foin en B7 ça va
ça a l'air très ça a l'air très bien
ça a l'air très bien
très bien je sais pas mais du coup
alors là on peut regarder aussi quand
même
il y a toujours un peu de gens
[Musique]
donc là il y a une grosse une grosse
merde
comment on les appelle c'est la le
prochain coup vous très très cher pas
forcément en termes de balle mais juste
c'est la position tellement différente
c'est un moment critique c'est vraiment
l'un des moments où tu dois passer du
temps
les deux se regardent
et vraiment passionnante passionnante
partie avec Magnus qui qui doit savoir
qu'il y a une part de bluff dans ce qui
fait
un rose par de risque mais bon un risque
un risque prévu à la maison
évidemment il n'avait pas cette position
là à l'entraînement mais il avait le
type de position c'est vraiment il sait
que l'ordinateur lui donne un titre
désavantage
d'un point c'est c'est la plus fort tu
gardes ton fou ouvert
mais bon mais bon les deux coups sont
regarde il y a un peu plus
[Musique]
de partout à surveiller il y a plein il
y a pas mal de choses c'est très
difficile
qui a plus que 47 minutes à la pendule
pour jouer 25 coups et au 25e coup tu as
seulement
10 secondes
[Musique]
parcours tu auras pas de rajout de temps
comme souvent on peut avoir souvent on
peut avoir du une demi-heure ou une rose
comme ça là il y a pas
donc
[Musique]
je me rappelle les cadences vraiment
hyper longues j'ai même fait des
tourments jeunes ou c'était tu avais un
premier contrôle de temps au 20e coup tu
vois
c'était vraiment
plus 1h40 plus 1h40 plus une demi-heure
encore 60e enfin oui enfin 2h40 plus 1h
plus après une demi-heure à partir de
60e
avec un journement enfin tu sais j'ai
fait un seul temps
40 et 1h15
c'était un 98
[Musique]
j'avais 8 ans
mais bon c'est pas moi qui a l'air je
m'appartient
tu joues assez vite
[Musique]
dans la même journée
la brasse double ronde à deux agents et
ce qui était très con mais juste il y en
avait pas compris qu'en fait quand ta
journée à Paris avec nul donc en fait
quand tu es mal il faut abandonner parce
que sinon enfin quand tu es très mal
quoi comme ça tu as à Paris avec zéro tu
vas jouer un genre plus faible parce que
sinon c'est la double peine ta journée
avec admis donc je vais en voir plus
fort et ensuite tu perds quand même et
voilà sauf que moi je voulais pas perdre
la chose c'était totalement perdant je
vais juste trop contente de
me direz j'ai pas dit j'ai toujours pas
perdu
du coup la femme encore ajournée tu
reprenais à 21h j'avais joué 13h aux
échecs de la même journée à 10 ans j'en
pouvais plus quoi
[Musique]
je vais aller me l'ordinateur
mais vraiment je me suis trompé
et ici alors oui
chez moi
et donne l'avantage blanc avec eux
c'est ok pour pour les blancs en
profondeur je suis en 25
mais bon c'est le cette pièce c'est
comme
des fois je reçois 18 en même temps
attends on va plus te voir pendant
quelques secondes mais il faut que je
ferme tout pour pouvoir ouvrir le slack
mais il est fermé
bien pour qu'on puisse bien te voir ce
que les gens sont là aussi pour te voir
hop là
[Musique]
alors
non j'ai pas mal de trucs
par contre là ça me fait un peu peur
mais on peut aller voir je pense que bon
alors j'ai un professionnel de Magnus on
norvégien malheureusement à moins que
dans le chat on est on est quelqu'un qui
qui puis fait traduire un norvégien à
l'oral bah écoute
sinon je peux vous faire le
confessionnal alors j'en ai j'ai trois
professionnels de maca
3 mais
[Musique]
mais je sais pas si c'est la même en
fait il y en a un c'est marqué
vidéo 2 donc attends je vais les prendre
déjà
je me demande si c'est pas un truc hyper
long je crois que c'est la même en fait
je crois que c'est les mêmes attends
mais je vais juste
norvégien et je te traduis n'importe
comment
je te fais une traduction quoi
j'ai aucune idée de la longueur de
attends je vais regarder dans mon petit
dossier
alors hop
attends ça c'est pas moi
j'enlève de partout non plus
alors
on commence
je crois que je vais mettre celui-là
voilà alors je te propose Yoshin
que je vous mette la confession de maca
et si tu veux on se dit de pause
elle dure quasiment 5 minutes
et je me dis que si on écoute caca
pendant 5 minutes comme tu veux
non non
de la cas pour Franck qui pose on
demandera à Yuma de nous faire un groupe
pavé
qui qui va résumer
ouais ouais tu peux raconter n'importe
quoi
et moi malheureusement je les écoute
jamais parce que je peux pas les voir
vous parler en anglais de façon on vous
mène à Cap pendant la pause
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour alors on a humé
qui nous a fait un super résumé
de la c'était juste la pause alors je
vais juste je vais vous lire
ce que nous a écrit youmé alors Faby
partie de la plus intéressante sa vie
est surprenant et il pense que c'est ok
pour moi mais c'est plus facile à jouer
pour les blancs s'habiller grand bling
il a déjà joué la ligne G4 de la partie
de gokuge c'est une partie intéressante
il pense que la partie Dali resa c'est
une bataille de mémoire pour sa propre
partie il a déjà joué beaucoup de
parties dans le même genre il a choisi
cavalier F3 pour changer un peu il s'en
fiche de l'ouverture il va lui jouer des
chèques ils attendent à une partie
longue et lente mais aime bien sa
position ok merci pour le résumé Yume je
te donnerai pas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
je te donne pas pour rester sur le
stream
et donc Magnus
qui a joué aussi
à jouer tu aurais eu ta suite c'est très
marrant ce cours il faut y penser déjà
il faut oser le jouer à quoi
tu remarqueras que que eux aussi c'est
quand même le coup proposé par Sox LOA
donc vraiment il est là il est là sur le
chat
des abonnements à ma chaîne il a
progressé
aux échecs d'offrir des abonnements à ma
chaîne et ça il le sait donc maintenant
il voit les coups de Magnus d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore qui ne connaît pas un pas
beaucoup de monde mais pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la chaîne de yosh av
vous savez quel stream sur sur twitch
maintenant depuis quelques mois
[Musique]
et du coup je vais vous envoyer le petit
lien de sa chaîne si vous voulez bien
sûr passer à faire un petit coucou
n'hésitez pas à aller voir sa chaîne et
et un petit follow et tout ça vous serez
parti de tout ce qui se passe sur sa
chaîne Youtube qui est très connue aussi
et c'est lucrativement alors
créativement j'étais avec lui
aujourd'hui au tournoi
en Espagne on y allait ensemble
et il y aurait une petite histoire
d'ailleurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
en vrai en vrai il est arrivé un truc de
ouf mais
c'est à moitié sa faute et à moitié
en face s'amuser je te raconte en gros
c'est un tournoi de
c'est Blitz je crois 7 + 3
c'est la ronde 2 donc c'est donc là
c'est pourtant classé ah non non
il y a quelques années il a jamais joué
il avait 1280 je crois en anglais
qui a 13 ans et
il a roi de pion contre roi mais les
pions très loin et de dames quoi
et en fait il lui reste 10 secondes à la
pendule mais il y a trois secondes
parcours donc tu vois en tout cas il
peut jamais perdre
et la fille elle continue par dépit
oui
standard jusque là il y a pas de souci
il fait promotion
mais quand c'est promotion ça c'est un
joueur d'Internet un petit peu
créativement
[Musique]
over the world et donc en fait et ben il
a fait promotion pion et il appuyé sur
la pendule la fille
elle appelle l'arbitré
il a il a il a pris le pion il a avancé
jusqu'à la 8e rangée il a appuie sur la
pendule et donc en plus c'est validé par
la pluie sur la pendule et donc lui
avant pas bon l'arbitre vient il dit bon
c'est le premier coup les gars c'est pas
grave fais attention etc bon jusque là
voilà et en plus voilà et
un peu après donc il avait deux pions
donc tu as compris je pense ce qui s'est
passé
alors la fille elle fait un coup illégal
alors lui il a un coup de la promotion
la fille elle a un coup de la promotion
avant pardon lui il y a un donc
créativement il a un coup la promotion
que ça donne et la fille elle met son
prix
bon créativement ne voit pas que la dame
que le roi il se met en échec et il
pousse son pion
et il a plus son appendu
et là la fille elle fait arbitre
franchement il était blasé de devoir
mettre perdu enfin
perdu
parce que il y avait que le roi mais
l'arbitre il était désolé il m'a attend
mais comment ça peut comment ça peut
t'arriver et
en fait donc il explique un peu à la
fille non mais franchement ça se fait
pas enfin regarde tu as droit à poil
enfin abandonne quoi tu vois ils adorent
se connaître enfin c'était bizarre un
peu et après il y a d'autres trucs qui
sont arrivés qui vont donner raison un
peu l'arbitre et la fille elle est c'est
bon moi je pensais que la fille elle
veut dire bon ok enfin je m'en donne
faim voilà ah non non règlement c'est ça
et il dit bon bah c'est comme ça bah moi
il faut que je mette nul parce que là et
la fille elle dit ah mais nous ça va
très bien tu as des dames de moi donc
évidemment que ça doit bien la nul et et
après donc Fabien créativement c'est
essayer de l'expliquer un petit peu que
ça se fait pas c'est quand même de la
triche c'est par faire plein de YouTube
tu vois quand tu fais une erreur ça
arrive mais quand tu volontairement tu
vois
en fait à la base enfin la base il y a
quelques années le premier couplégal
perdait en
partie
gaz tu perds même encore il y a bien
longtemps
on pouvait prendre le roi que en blitz
mais évidemment mais tu laisses ton
emprise l'autre le manger et puis gagner
la partie quoi alors après on a dit non
on mange jamais le roi mais quand il y a
un coup de gueule ça gagne et
après en fait ils ont instauré la règle
de pour recadrer la promotion que
justement toutes ces promotions mal
faites et c'est considéré comme des
couilles légaux mais vu que c'est le
premier coup illégal perd de la partie
c'est arrivé même au top niveau je crois
que c'est arrivé à Topaloff
ils laissent le pion bon et puis premier
couplé les galères perd la partie et du
coup ils ont rechangé la règle de
au lieu de dire on pas de soupe sur la
promotion
et dire bâtard il pousse le pion il dit
dames bon d'accord ça se fait pas mais
en fait c'est pas grave t'arrêtes la
pendule tu mets une dame
au lieu d'être
de revenir la règle sur cette règle la
fidèle se dit amor va faire un truc
c'est maintenant c'est le deuxième
couple légal qui perdue
[Musique]
si vous mettez une tour retournée c'est
une tour c'est que la fille la fille
quand tu lui expliquais que c'est tu
vois mais moi à un moment donné il y a
rien à faire
[Musique]
dangereuse de d'agir contre son intérêt
en fait c'est la règle qui est mal faite
à partir du moment où la joueuse n'a pas
abandonné bon la règle est comme ça
tu vois c'est pareil elle peut rien
donc après être là être là à chercher la
petite bête c'est juste ça moi qui m'a
qui m'a un peu énervé et la fille quand
tu lui quand tu lui dis j'essaye
d'admirer les gestes fair-play et de
jamais critiquer un geste qui ou la
personne se montre pas faire play quand
c'est dans son intérêt bon enfin tu peux
pas tu peux pas obliger la personne à
faire à faire un geste contre elle-même
alors que elle respecte leur ex parce
que marrant c'est qu'en fait
à ce moment-là Fabien il lui dit enfin
il était là il a confronte un peu et il
boit de l'arbitre il lui dit matin tu
m'as fait trois coups idéaux à chaque
fois je te dis non mais c'est pas grave
joue et c'est toi la première fois mais
tu me tues en fait
et elle a dit oui mais t'as pas et moi
je réclame c'était oh là là c'était tu
vois en fait c'était et moi j'étais là
j'étais tout j'étais et là et moi à un
moment je le dis là tu mets ton roi tu
habites en échec et elle dit oui mais il
a parlé tu vois genre elle est au
courant de toutes les règles ça va très
bien mais c'était juste ce qu'on a le et
il y a son père à côté qui était fier
enfin tout allait bien juste
c'est souvent les aucun problème ah bah
oui c'est clair mais bon voilà c'était
l'épisode qui lui arrivait ce matin
[Musique]
en sur un vrai chez qui ouvrirait
d'échec vous mettez le pion sur la
promotion vous changez votre pion en ce
que vous voulez et vous appuyez ne
faites pas promotion j'appuie parce que
ça c'est online sur Internet ah oui je
pousse mon pion ça fait directement une
dame mais en live c'est il y a pas de
magie
il faut penser à ça et c'est bête hein
mais c'est vrai que c'est des trucs
qu'on pense pas forcément été quand tu
vas faire un tournoi online comme tu as
enfin un tournoi en IRL et que tu es pas
habitué à tout ça mais il y a plein de
règles qui sont pas des gens qui doivent
savoir etc
intéressante tant qu'on est
sur puis après on passera quand même
partir en direct mais
oui tu peux arrêter la pendule si tu as
besoin d'une deuxième dame ou d'un
troisième cavalier Ouattara tu as le
droit de pousser le pion
arrêter la pendule non pas appuyer mais
arrêtez la pendule et appeler l'arbitre
pour lui dire j'ai besoin de je sais pas
quoi
en pratique ça se fait pas comme ça
enfin
normalement il y a toutes les pièces à
disposition ou même parfois quand
l'arbitre un tournoi après studieux voit
que le joueur la joueuse va promotion
elle va avoir besoin il apporte toutes
les pièces parce qu'évidemment ça porte
que la dame tu donnes un indice sur un
promotion de l'âme c'est le bon coup ou
ça apporte que le cavalier c'était
encore fini
bon je dis ça je dis rien mais
ça peut vite donc il apporte même un fou
et une tour et compris même si c'est
totalement idiot et puis et puis voilà
bref alors il s'est passé
soit ce que je prends à 8 intermédiaires
si on prend un rabbit et 3 par exemple
peu importe mais toi tu parles de fois
je crois ici
après moi j'aimerais bien manger là
d'être regardé mon fou je sais pas ce
qui est le mieux
c'est juste pour dire que
non pas la nuit
je pensais peut-être une répétition
possible comme ça et ça fait nul comme
répétition mais je peux aussi essayer
pour le matin voilà je sais que c'était
mais en tout cas c'est les thèmes c'est
le thème intéressant et trop sur case
blanche je suis un cavalier E5 qui a du
H5 il y a spion qui est toujours un
petit peu faible donc mais bon il y a
clairement plus qu'un pour le noir pour
Aniche
et c'est la partie
[Musique]
de la défense
de rester dans ce secteur là pour garder
un petit peu
les pièces et dans mon site La Valette
jouer fois je crois j'ai du mal à le
penser non non
mais en fait pourquoi
ouais
ça protège sa protège quoi
en souffrance
parce qu'il y a il y a un toit là mais
bon je suis pas sûr que changer les
pièces ça soit si bon que ça pour les
blancs quand même parce que plus je
change moi j'ai
comme j'ai un peu moins de regarder les
pièces quand même
on va voir comment karting va jouer ça
c'est intéressant
là il y a tout ça débat sur le soutien
au youtubeurs youtubeuses non merci
sauvé que c'est le meilleur
très généreux et ça se voit tout de
suite là il repère les coups de cartes
maintenant c'est récompensé ça marche
comme ça de toute façon je l'échec à
Magnus il était juste très généreux dans
une vie précédente
dans cette même vie c'est encore mieux
alors
Faby que nous fait
de la partie il y a un monde où on est
je fais mater avec le fou encore
ici c'est passé beaucoup de choses
de fou et la dame elle est en H4 tu
avais proposé
les pièces aussi
et sur ce site
[Musique]
de nécessité quoi c'est le coup que tu
fais en disant mais pourquoi je me suis
embarquée dans cette galère
j'aime pas ce qu'il fait
là
la dernière fois qu'on a commencé cette
position les Blancs ont des grosses
faiblesses à la dame le pianiste il est
fort tant qu'il investisse mais il y a
plein de variantes où il finit perdu
donc les blancs doivent mater ou c'est
peut-être mal il faut que avec ça
c'est vraiment le coup de bon ok j'ai
pas d'attaque je suis mal et voilà
une tactique là
non mais d'accord mais juste faut des
trois si c'est un coup de défense quoi
statiquement moins bien donc
à être la faiblesse de la position et
c'est pour ça alors je comprends mais
tous les trois ça ça défend contre vous
prend aussi ça le meilleur coup mais si
c'est le meilleur coût c'est que la
position va mal oui
ce petit
alors je voudrais faire ça ça et ça pour
clouer mais j'ai un fou j'ai un peu en
C4 donc je vais pousser mon pion
s'attaquer une pièce et quand tu bouges
et ben je peux manger et te clouer ça
c'est joli hein comme comme tactique
on a vu que ça a marché pas
dans une position bien précise à quand
le foot en 4
il y avait fou prendre un point et cette
avec fou des cinq échecs
tout à l'heure dans une position et donc
maintenant il est parti manger pion le
pion ici ça fait quand même peur j'ai le
et un truc comme ça ça fait pas peur ça
alors
j'avais pas vu
c'est la même chose tu fais faut prendre
juste un problème
de rien de rien
donc en fait ben écoute il mange les
pions il a un pion passé maintenant il
met dans maxi va revenir à priori en o7
peut-être derrière c'est chaud
qu'il était
marié à l'héritière du pétrole Algérie
mais
depuis ce livre il a rejoué mais après
c'était quelqu'un qui avait quasiment
arrêté de jouer donc
ce qui était bizarre c'était de le
revoir jouer sur les tournois online où
il
marchait bien après il arrêtait d'être
invité à cet endroit
voilà
mais bon enfin de toute façon oui il
jouera
[Musique]
au départ notamment de Maxime
bachelagrave
alors
on a rien c'est ça
la recette
un coup magique mais j'ai pas de C4
aussi
ça marche pas non
[Musique]
mais ça ne marche pas
mais j'ai pas le temps de poser mon pied
et donc
les noirs
est-ce que tu as un petit B4 et d'un
coup un TAC là et je te cloue je
continue
[Musique]
je suis d'accord
encore un peu
j'ai le temps de refaire
c'est pas très Vial quand même on sent
que ça doit pas tenir pour les blancs
mais
il pose des petites questions à chaque
coup quoi
mais bon
c'était vraiment ça venait d'une
position on adorait les blancs
[Musique]
alors attends je comprends pas
donc on parle de
on parlait de ça non
début ça me laisse strictement rien
moi je pousse je pousse je pousse et je
verrai
mais tu menaces rien du tout
de toute façon il y a le plus rapide
[Rires]
j'ai arrêté de traverser si tu avais
rigolé comme ça de mes coups mais bon je
te je te l'ai fait donc tu auras le
droit tu auras le droit de ne pas
merci je voulais faire quoi pour te
clouer mais en fait vous savez que
clouage ça arrive avec avec des
couvertes bon euh ça rime pas trop mais
en vrai les deux thèmes sont pareils en
fait parce que d'un côté je te trouve tu
me découvre donc en fait elle va trop
attention à ça
[Rires]
il y a encore une enfilade qui se
dessine
pour éviter
on y arrive
bisous bisous bisous
alors donc dame G3 on garde un petit peu
la pression mais est-ce que je peux
juste comme ça le 7 est-ce que
tu arrives à faire quelque chose
à mon fou il est pas bien je suis
d'accord
je suis trop lent est-ce que toi tu peux
garder madame par là-bas pour essayer de
faire des découvertes enfin découvrir
a fait un peu penser à la partie de
Magnus alors pas du tout d'imposition
mettre dans le style le groupe champ de
moins la nécessité de trouver du jeu
mais il y en a pas non plus tout de
suite tout de suite
mais en même temps c'est pas très Vial
pour les Noirs quoi
alors ici si la possibilité F4
je suis pas hyper ravi de bouger le plus
bref je préfère bouger le plus rare mais
bon
sur dame cette fois ça protège un ça
gagne du temps un peu
c'est
un coup qui est moche mais qui peut être
fort
H4 moi c'est mon roi avant pour
le bien et donc F4 j'aime pas mais après
là ça protège rien ça
sinon ça relou quand même
ok
est-ce qu'on pourrait
[Musique]
en est là
et alors on en a ici qui s'est passé
quoi le tour C8 tours c'est lui faire
froid
de H6 du coup qu'on est proposé
tout à l'heure sur
la phrase c'est vraiment acceptée d'être
un peu moins bien et dire c'est pas
grave je vais la tenir t'inquiète mais
parce que là il y a
une blanc peuvent tourner alors bon un
fil rouge il est assez recomplex
ça ne dérange pas s'il sait que c'est
égal du premier météorique ça le dérange
pas de que l'autre il tourne il se dit
pas qu'il a moins de 50% de chance
d'équité on va dire mais
bon moi j'aurais été très tenté de
prendre F3 simplifier la position faire
nul
dans le fou il y a un monde où justement
F4 peut arriver alors il faut le
préparer évidemment ça a fait Bill roi
mais le cavalier il a pas de casse table
et ça c'est vraiment nécessaire si tout
à l'heure on avait proposé dans le
mettre en D4 après avoir joué 5 et donc
là il était fixé en quatre etc
il a pas de cas de force et
donc si les pions blancs arrivent à
avancer F4 5 de 6 bah on peut se faire
rouler dessus quoi donc évidemment vous
voyez la jauge c'est génial les Noirs
ont leurs atouts le pion a qui a pas
commencé à avancer mais ça je le dis
depuis le début il peut courir très vite
quand il se met en marche grâce au
foget7 qui contrôle la case 1 donc
contrôler la carte de promotion en un
pion c'est très important pour deux
raisons déjà s'il y arrive on va pouvoir
reprendre la pièce blanche qui qui va
devoir se sacrifier mais en plus ça
évite que la tour adverse se mettre sur
la colonne du pion un jeune donc
[Musique]
les Noirs ont leurs atouts c'est censé
être égal mais
ça montre que tu as autant moi je
m'attendais à c'était plus style nul en
quelques cours et en fait ça peut durer
encore si les deux joueurs veulent faire
durer cette partie ça peut durer très
longtemps avec même un moment une
position qui devient très complète
ici les deux joueurs veulent tout de
suite ça c'est pas le trouver un moyen
de simplifier la position ou le reposer
je sais pas quoi
bon est-ce que est-ce que aussi c'est
une possibilité ici j'imagine que le
défi V4 c'est qui peut-être qui veut que
je dessine
[Musique]
tu fais un gros pari avec les Noirs
quand même
là tu peux être foutu tu sais que tu
peux être foutu comme ça donc E6 moi
j'aimais bien quand ça gagne
plus solide mais attention
c'est clairement une question
quelle il faut il faut répondre
rapidement
si je fais F4 j'imagine qu'elle va
laisser 4 tu es quand même venu là
peut-être pour ça
[Musique]
je pense à ça
c'est
ultra compliqué
[Musique]
mais ouais on voit à quel point ça
devient compliqué alors après plus team
qui a laissé 6 d'ailleurs
c'est très chaud très très chaud
[Musique]
de moins intéressantes
j'ai l'impression que c'est pour
l'instant c'est plus westlé
malheureusement pour les fans de Fiero
qui plus Wesley qui essaie de jouer mais
Fiero par exemple il a pas pris il
voulait pas il voulait garder les pièces
pour jouer le meilleur coup d'après
l'ordinateur
alors on regarde la carte
allez on va voir un peu ce qui va
aller blanc contre Ariane tari donc Naka
qui a dit par rapport enfin c'est dans
sa profession qui a dit qu'il voulait vu
une partie de l'échec tranquille sans
trop de théorie et je suis chose échec
et mettre la pression d'être une partie
longue un petit changement de structure
avec les noirs qui ont le dessin qui est
le pion 4 qui est venu s'échanger donc
les Noirs maintenant ont un avantage au
centre avec le pion E5
le blanc non plus qu'un pion 1 2 3 mais
les blancs toujours la paire de fou donc
c'est vraiment typique de ce que
nakabuler
alors après encore une fois c'est pas de
rien il peut pas te mécontente sa
position c'est égal avec la loi il y a
pas longtemps il a pas vraiment souffert
juste 5 c'est la petite
concession je disais mais
là ça a l'air ça a l'air d'aller très
bien
parce que j'ai du mal à voir comment
activer la paire de fou des blancs
d'actualité qui menace quand même pas
mal de petites choses
et je risque
là qu'on sait pas encore comment on va
activer le fou mais bon sur le long
terme peut-être faire tout recap le tour
en E1 taper ici et essayer d'ouvrir un
peu ses fous c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident
peut-être un C4 même un roi champ F4 ici
à un moment donné d'ouvrir
la centralisation des Noirs qui
ce qui leur donne la qualité quoi
il y a des idées mais j'ai un peu du mal
à croire
et bien sûr défendre par tour séance
c'est pas du tout un coup vous n'êtes
pas monopoliser une tour pour défendre
un petit pion comme ça ces trois j'ai au
minimum cavalier V3 et se fout devient
complètement nul
donc
elle a fait la tête donc non
[Musique]
il considère que ça simplifie trop la
position je sais pas après il faut voir
une alternative
est-ce que
si je pars à la menace avec un couple du
style dame G6
est-ce que je suis pas content là
tu prends je prends du purin je
t'attaque là
c'est plus du tout la même manière mais
moi j'ai aucun envie de F6
pour cette diagonale
parce que je monte un petit peu au chat
tourner cette par exemple ça peut être
très dangereux avec des coups je crois
qu'il y a quelque chose mais bon je vais
faire un mauvais coup juste pour voir
ici par exemple voilà il y a des idées
qu'il faut prendre S5 déjà
et je mange et là je dois avoir
peut-être un cavalier F6 qui va qui va
marcher avec fourchette d'ailleurs je
suis deux fois dessus et si tu manges
mon cavalier et ben je bouge mon fou là
ou là ça fera échec a découvertes et ça
fera moins de prochain coup avec des G7
[Musique]
et une question et puis bah voilà et du
coup est-ce que je suis obligé de la
bouger parce que si je prends un C2
si je fais ça
je pense que je peux gagner une pièce
[Rires]
je pensais à un truc comme ça
donc je me suis dit
en fait j'ai du cavalier
parce qu'en fait
ce que j'ai pensé je te montre un petit
peu
une pièce de plus parce que si tu prends
la et ben je suis fort chat sauf que
tout le monde ok maintenant si je parle
en vert si je fais à l'envers que je
fais ça tu manges de la tour pour éviter
tout reprendre mais j'ai quand même
qu'elle va dire
mais tu as tout recommencer tu peux
prendre un point tu prends un
dimanche
[Musique]
[Rires]
simplification difficile de savoir quel
est le mieux objectif effectivement et
difficile savoir quel est le mieux
contrarié quand et Carole Nakamura
ils ont fait un coup à jouer avec 30
secondes 30 minutes chacun 38
à 5 parties précisément
[Musique]
et là on est
une qualité de plus
et les deux pièces sont pas trop mal
parce que le fou en cessé ce sera
excellent mais le cavalier a des bonnes
casques etc est-ce que tu vois mon écran
avec les deux coups en vert fluo de
Abdou pour deux casques
il a fait alors attends on va parce
qu'il s'est passé on s'est arrêté à fond
les trois plus ou moins alors on avait
parlé de tout ça c'est ça qu'on en a pas
du tout parlé et ça m'a l'air ça m'avait
l'air bizarre mais il veut ouh là là
c'est joli
là
tour et le pion c'est 5 boum je mange là
[Musique]
on y va c'est moi qui joue attaque après
bon alors il aime pas mais
ça c'est toujours le problème c'est
non mais après peut-être que c'est pas
mais bon
mais il y a du jeu
[Musique]
il faut que tu
serais terrifié avec la loi Laurent
très bien
et du coup finance qui avait les parents
à 8 mois je l'avais mis il a mis en 7
ans
[Musique]
on peut pas prendre
à cause de
donc ici on a eu sur sur tour de cartes
on a eu mais je sais qu'en bas et
surtout derrière on est revenu et il a
refait ton des quatre
merci
qui est vraiment beau en fait quand tu
dis ouais a priori on va en bouffer pour
les 20 prochaines années à découvrir
en fait n'importe qui quand je te dis
des joueurs qui qui sont maintenant très
connu on voit
guéri on voit
saut de même NACA etc
j'en vois pas qui dans une position qui
à peu près égale ou même avec les Noirs
mais en général essayer vraiment de
gagner à chaque fois
tu vois et c'est vraiment cette nouvelle
génération de jeunes qui fait tout pour
gagner toutes les parties et ça je
trouve que c'est je crois que à chaque
génération il y a eu des joueurs plus ou
moins compatibles alors après avec un
biais quand même quand
Magnus par exemple c'est un genre hyper
compatible mais bon il a un problème
c'est qu'il est meilleur donc en fait
dans la position égale en espérance est
toujours par défaut supérieur à 50% quoi
mais
c'est vrai que ce Magnus il a combien de
fois il a gagné des parties en 6 heures
de jeu alors que c'était égal depuis le
début
mais ouais non c'est impressionnant
alors après il y a aussi à chaque
génération il y a des joueurs
très forts très tranquilles par exemple
guéri maintenant il essaye de
complexifier un peu son style depuis
quelques années mais
dès qu'il était très fort à part c'est
très jeunes années où il sacrifiait tout
il a toujours été
avant lui enfin des joueurs pétrole Siam
bien avant etc toute génération il y a
eu des joueurs qui étaient contents
Wesley content de faire nul quoi il y a
des joueurs qui détestent
tous les niveaux c'est vraiment une
question de style c'est sûr que ça fait
plaisir juste à un moment
il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui préfèrent
gagner perdre plutôt que de faire de nul
et il y a des joueurs qui beaucoup de
joueurs qui préfèrent faire de nul moi
je suis vraiment te donner je déteste
perdre très mauvaise perdante très
mauvaise gagnante aussi donc
je préfère vraiment faire de nul la
douleur de la défaite n'est pas compensé
par le plaisir de la victoire
donc
maintenant après il y a aussi
parfois cette tu crois que tes chances
sont supérieures à 50%
tu peux croire
il y a plein de vidéos
[Musique]
ça va peut-être pas suffisant mais là il
va falloir faire plusieurs
erreurs pour se retrouver perdant quoi
qui va bloquer etc et moi j'ai un peu
passé qui est soutenu par ce cavalier là
il va falloir échanger
pour le gain c'est jouer pour la perdre
même si la refusé la nul il y a quelques
coups je trouve pas une idée là pour
essayer de la jouer et puis les blancs
non plus c'est quand les gens qui ont
les plus faibles je trouve que les noirs
et puis le roi blanc aussi
parce que sinon là il se passe
donc ok moi c'est trois c'est la partie
rien de spécial
que nous propose Magic ici
j'ai vu sur Twitter sans confessionnal
traduire en langage par une partie juste
il avait un plan deux étapes pour pour
revenir dans le tournoi vu qu'il y a
toujours pas gagné une partie la
première c'est de changer de look donc
il s'est rasé pas les cheveux la barbe
et la deuxième partie de son plan deux
étapes c'était de faire ce qu'il faisait
il y a quelques temps donc le sacrifier
un pion juste pour prendre le centre et
attaquer
donc il a fait son plan deux étapes
après il faut voir si ça va marcher
comme il a dit
ok alors on va revenir un petit peu en
arrière on s'est arrêté
[Musique]
alors
un pion de moins tu dois garder les
pièces cavaliers prend faut prendre ce
matin
ça va être vu bien sûr par Aniche dame
G6
est-ce que c'est en fait la finale elle
a l'air pas terrible non
[Musique]
le roi blanc sera durablement un peu
plus fort un peu plus en sécurité on va
dire
vu qu'il a trois pions devant lui et les
Noirs m'ont plus que deux mais ça a
l'air quand même
bien égal tout ça
quoi que
est-ce qu'il y a des idées
ça ça tu prends je peux pousser pas de
se on a pas tout à l'heure il est
très mauvais il a pas de case et du coup
ça a force la tour à venir ici si un
jour je mangerai
tu risques de perdre ton fou par rapport
à la croissance ça va encore mais
attention que tu as aussi ça en l'air
prise et quand tu prends B2 je prends C4
les blancs Magnus a récupéré son pion et
attention qu'il est faiblesse reste je
suis pas fan il y a eu quoi là la place
on est comme ça on est comme ça
et moi cette position et du temps on
parlait du temps me guérir il y a plus
que 18 minutes pour jouer 16 coups
on peut imaginer tu vois il reste 16
coups dans les cadences avec un crémant
et ben on a souvent on a 30 secondes par
coup généralement donc 30 secondes pour
16 coups fais 8 minutes si tu ajoutes et
c'est comme si en fait à guérit ici il
lui restait plus que 10 minutes dans la
vente enfin dans les dans les cadences
normales 10 minutes plus 30 secondes
parcours si tu veux
40e c'est un peu pareil c'est
l'équivalent donc là c'est pas beaucoup
c'est un peu le direct note là pour pour
guérir je pense parce que je vous
rappelle que la cadence c'est deux
heures ko avec un rajoutant de
rajoutant de 10 secondes par coup au 40e
coup donc là il y a quand même très très
peu de temps de rajouts et là c'est ko
jusque 40e déjà
plus simple à jouer pour les blancs oui
oui parce que en fait moi j'aimais ça
j'ai des faiblesses qui sont là qui
pourrit toi tu as aussi des un moyen de
pouvoir attaquer sur F2 donc tu as
plusieurs moyens mais de manière
générale c'est quand même facile pour
moi
avance pas trop et ça a bien passé alors
je sais pas si je fais F4 ça m'a l'air
un petit peu crumble
[Musique]
je pensais aussi à ça
de garder c'est pas trop créer de
faiblesse tu vas faire
là je mange là-haut
ou et ben écoute j'en avoir le un
message comme quoi l'Armageddon de Abdou
cache se jouer dans 19 minutes donc ça a
fait nul ouais voilà bon on s'en doutait
hein on l'avait dit que c'était ça
allait être là la partie qui allait
faire nul donc on a on a déjà tous les
deux perdus on a mis 1-01 bravo
bravo l'équipe donc à 20h20 c'est
l'heure de Plus belle la vie
je sais pas
[Rires]
si ça ça
[Musique]
pour ceux qui regardent plus belle la
vie là on a quand même on a quand même
le départage d'abdu et de gouquet vous
savez qu'on regardait en tout cas si
[Musique]
vous regardez on est dimanche je crois
que c'était pas le weekend donc ça va
vous allez échapper aujourd'hui
[Musique]
au Cap d'Agde en 2013 etc
très longtemps
[Musique]
son personnage je ne sais pas
c'est très grand très grand
non pas très grand
ça fait trop longtemps
mais après un moment il avait dû arrêter
parce que en fait quand tu restes trop
longtemps dans l'ordre de série après tu
peux plus trouver aucun autre rôle quoi
donc financièrement c'était génial pour
lui à la fin il allait vraiment très
très bien par épisode mais un moment si
vous voulez faire
autre chose au théâtre au cinéma
il fallait arrêter à ce moment là quoi
voilà
mais ok
[Musique]
je peux comprendre puisque c'est vrai
que positionnellement ça fout c'est une
horreur et on va vouloir l'échanger donc
aussi
une pièce parce qu'il peut toujours y
avoir c'est ça aussi
mais donc là la structure devient
marrante avec la création d'un pion
passé chacun maintenant donc
l'option e pas très fort le pureté aussi
parce que bon il bloque le fou pour
l'instant mais il peut aussi avancer
vite en descartant de trois et plus si
affinités
donc
il y a plus beaucoup de pièces sur
l'échiquier mais on sait que ma news
aussi n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de
pièces pour créer des problèmes et le
roi noir
toujours un peu faible
autant le roi blanc même il y a plein de
monde où tu fais orage de F4 etc enfin
il sera il sera toujours relativement
safe normalement pas passer ma news
pour le protéger et donc par l'instant
on va pas du tout comment il peut être
en danger mais
il aura toujours que de pions pour le
protèger quoi c'est pas beaucoup
moi je commence à bien aimer les blancs
surtout quand je vois le temps de guéri
là
15 minutes à jouer
victoire
après il l'a battu il y a pas longtemps
mais en fait c'est vrai que anus il fait
beaucoup beaucoup de nuls et il y a
plein de même sur ça
et alors il faut pas le faire devant lui
c'est de le mettre très en colère c'est
vrai
j'imagine un peu c'est pas vrai parce
que c'est un joueur qui joue enfin en
fait il fait beaucoup de nul mais il
veut gagner
un attaquant contrarié
il essaie parfois de montrer puis en
fait
le deuil de mes parties d'attaque c'est
pas grave de temps en temps j'essaye
encore et puis après non c'est bon j'ai
compris c'est plus pour moi
alors j'ai vu que sur Youtube on nous
demande de voir fierou alors j'ai ouvert
le chat Youtube c'est vrai alors déjà
première chose pour ceux qui sont sur
Youtube
bonjour à vous ça vous que seulement 21
pour 29 pardon pour 100 des des viewers
YouTube sont abonnés à la chaîne
c'est fou il suffit d'un clic
un clic la cloche la cloche abonné donc
je vous conseille de de vous abonner
c'est gratuit et vous pouvez vous
pourrez apprécier toutes les infos tous
les nouveautés de ce qu'on fera vous
sera en ligne les vidéos tous les trucs
sur sur Youtube donc en tout cas
suivez-nous et alors pour les messages
oui on va aller voir filou donc on a
cinq parfums en même temps Furious c'est
d'abord ça qui était la moins
intéressante de 5 mais là j'ai vu qu'il
s'est passé quand même pas mal de choses
[Musique]
un gros risque de
choses là
on va regarder alors attends
derrière attention le foot aime défendu
il rêve 4K
alors prise là
je sais pas trop
c'est la moitié en prise dans ce
cavalier
tu vois si il faut faire ça
[Musique]
mais bon je suis pas sûr que tout soit
mieux avec les noirs
et je peux pas manger là parce que tu
auras tout rentrer
je sais pas parce qu'en fait ton pion il
est là mais bon
ce pion est tellement fort en fait que
je suis pas sûr que que l'avantage soit
si obvius oui puisque au mieux pour
aller noir t'arrives à changer elle pion
on décide contre le pion à 7
[Musique]
comme ça il doit être bien nul quoi
alors là je suis en train de voir Magnus
je sais pas si mon écran là
on a pas reçu le il vient de dire qu'il
a raté Dame des 6
il pense qu'il a un petit peu il est un
petit peu mieux
on va l'avoir aussi je peux peut-être
vous la montrer mais
c'est rare parce que on voit que du
point de vue objectif donc en fait ça
doit après ça confirme notre sentiment à
nous mais
si tu remets la position de Magnus
l'ordinateur il donnait totalement égal
on disait qu'on prenait les blancs tous
les jours quoi
quand même très rarement et il est
objectif c'est comme personne c'est pas
du tout un joueur comme cramique qui va
toujours dire je suis gagnant je suis
gagnant non non Magnus si il dit la
vérité de ce qu'il pense et
il pense rarement être mieux quand il
l'est pas et donc là il pense être mieux
dans cette position
alors que l'ordi affiche 00 donc c'est
très intéressant mais ça montre que
humainement ça doit être difficile c'est
possible aussi que à je pense être moins
bien
il y a surtout cet aspect temps aussi
avec moi qui me fait peur et ce fou qui
est pourri en fait
il y a la seule pratique au delà de la
position que j'ai un pion passé je sais
pas si je F4 ou pas je sais pas si je
peux manger là pendant que tu as mangé
là et après essayer de jouer contre ceux
qui ont des cinq qui est faible je sais
pas comment ça se passe mais dans tous
les cas il y a quelques problèmes
pratiques à régler mais il y a aussi ce
fou à 8 qui est mauvais et il y a aussi
très peu de temps chez Aniche 14 quoi à
faire en 12 minutes 30
juste pour revenir sur l'évaluation 00
la différence entre le jeu humain
imaginez une position comme celle-là qui
est qui est objectivement un gars ça
devient du point de vue l'ordinateur je
parfais il va toujours faire match nul
mais où à chaque coup les Blancs ont le
choix entre 10 coups qui qui laisse la
position comme égale elle est noire 94
ou deux
bah du coup humainement c'est très
difficile à jouer pour le noir et là on
a un peu dans cette situation ce qui a
gagné joue parfaitement s'il y a deux
jours je veux pas faire parfaitement ça
va faire match nul mais je veux
parfaitement mettre plus difficile à
faire pour Annie je que pour ma nièce
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il a un autre coup
ça c'est une bonne idée
je vais peut-être même ça
c'est un peu
même ça
ça fait juste nul non
ça c'est ce que je voulais dire ça c'est
totalement nul et les pions sont très
bien placés
il sait que si
il échange ces deux pions contre le pur
B2 ça sera toujours nul
garder un peu le contrôle pour pas qu'il
puisse pousser des pions etc
tu vois tu peux pas pousser des cas tu
peux pas mais en fait
un petit peu la poussée des quatre
on va voir attention Magnus
d'entrer la tour et puis après
en tout cas on contrôle la case des
quatre
et ouais il y a plusieurs
trucs et des quatre est-ce que je peux
jouer des quatre
est-ce que je peux jouer des 4
alors mon idée j'ai bien vu que je
perdais un pion
mais je veux réussir à changer des
pièces par amplifier
dans quel sens
et donc la dame prend on a dit que c'est
totalement nulle
mais celle-ci est-ce qu'elle est alors
déjà
une bonne la troisième
moi je veux donner les pions pour
échanger le fou et m'activer essayer
d'arriver
ici la finale contre tour d'âme 32 elle
doit être nulle relativement facile plus
difficile que sur les bases évidemment
mais le relativement facile donc
pour la nuit
prise près 0 F1
tu as pas proposé 5 et 6 x 4
et encore une autre
ça
c'est pas lequel je sais pas
tout de suite et puis
c'est nul
du coup
bienvenue à toi
ça risque de faire nul en fait très vite
donc c'est bientôt l'heure de Plus Belle
La Vie les gars 20h20
voilà partie qui va commencer de bouquet
plein de choses un peu de partout alors
on peut aller voir rapidement enfin un
petit tour avant de d'aller voir le
l'armée
tout à l'heure on en parlait 6 avec les
vis-à-vis
là
si bien sûr je prends ici je vais faire
madame vous avez vu le Fou est au milieu
et on a fait une sorte de découverte si
tu prends ici
cette échec intermédiaire qui permet de
pouvoir garder mon fou et ensuite de
manger là j'ai quand même du matériel
d'avance ou pas non j'ai pas de matériel
d'avance mais je ne connaissons
il a joué tour progressiste là c'est
marrant parce qu'il laisse la dame en
prise pour menacer mat ici et surtout
prends aussi
ah oui c'est moi qui m'attend ouais
[Musique]
tu imagines oh
c'est un truc
[Musique]
[Rires]
un
ok donc
un peu plus faible mais au final
a commencé est-ce que on dirait pas voir
ça
on va voir ça quand même
est-ce que tu as un résultat bon je
pense que tu vas sur le tien tu vas
rester sans ton résultat bah écoute moi
aussi
moi aussi en cas de match nul
bon après là c'était pas du tout Paris
par rapport au marine mais oui
moi j'ai parlé sur une victoire de
Google
donc on a une vraie catalane cette
fois-ci et vous voyez Abdou il sait
qu'il faut pas mettre le cavalier en
cette fin
c'est qu'il faut récupérer le pion C4
il a pas joué
alors comment on joue ici
c'est 3
tours
donc je vous rappelle la cadence on a 10
minutes pour les blancs contre 600030
contre 7 minutes pour les noirs et les
noirs peuvent faire nuls en cas de nul
les Noirs gagnent la partie quoi
ça simplifie grandement la position donc
la Loire peuvent vraiment pas être moins
bien la structure d'option est
maintenant symétrique mais aucun
problème de développement pour les Noirs
attention d'ailleurs au fur et F2 un
petit cavalier G4 un moment ça peut être
lourd
[Musique]
donc ça se passe très bien voilà de
princesse c'est quand même laver des
chèques
à trois alors
que je travaille j'aime bien aussi
3 et du coup bah c'est déjà pas terrible
pour la case en cas de cavalier
je pense pas qu'il va bouger son cavaler
comme ça je pense qu'il va juste jouer à
et sur à 5 bouger la dame de Damas
[Musique]
5 je peux pas
5 mais je peux sortir mon fou peut-être
le focus sortir un jour
tombe D8 bref il faut calculer ça ça et
bouge ça m'a l'air assez chaud
ça a pas l'air de marcher donc tu fais
et après il y a des autres cases
[Musique]
c'est pas si mal
placé mais bon alors elle va finir
enceinte mais
elle va devoir rejouer quoi
on a eu la partie je crois que c'était
saut blanc contre guéri gris à la fin il
a une pièce de plus et il a pris la
perpète
il a pas compris il a fallu s'empêcher
le but c'est pas de c'est pas de gagner
la partie quand elle est noire c'est
juste de pas perdre parce que dans les
règles c'est un magazine
exactement c'est ça
le 16 juin sera un jour férié pour
souffle en prochain et c'est possible
c'est possible que le 16 juin ce soir
[Musique]
ça pue
ça sent le match
ça sent le mat je crois qu'il y a encore
une fois tu as fait un bon Paris
[Musique]
par jour et il va pas faut prendre
pas de risque
ça fait peur
[Musique]
il a encore du temps là pendule
E3 F3 je peux pas défendre comment je
défends
[Musique]
on a la jauge et on est moins fort que
encore beaucoup moins fort que pour
débute
[Musique]
et ça j'ai quand même gagné juste après
mais
je streamais je me prends un message
et heureusement il s'est trompé juste
après
donc là mon cette dame de moi
mais
il y a aussi que de mauvaises pièces et
il va y avoir deux pions
il a vraiment très mal joué
une non partie de d'abdu Abou qui fait
qui fait pas très très bon tournant à
l'inconnu quand même
plus plus fort dans ces cadences de ce
qu'il est quand même il a du monde même
de rap
hein
pour gagner
[Musique]
j'ai oublié que tu dois gagner dans ma
tête
est-ce qu'il va pas le seul parti
[Musique]
qui ressemble un petit peu à la partie
qu'il a eu contre chirou
en partie classique
[Musique]
ouais je crois que c'est perdu là
pour nul ou abandon c'est la même chose
est-ce que les éloquantes pour le je
pense pas hein
[Musique]
historiquement ça avait déjà compté je
me rappelle ta roman qui a perdu des
points lourds
masque normal
je commence à partir avec les noirs et
moins de temps bon
ok bon du coup ensuite
[Musique]
alors on a carvana mammedia complètement
gagnant avec les Noirs je vais vous
montrer la partie avec les caméras ici
on est comme ça que s'est-il passé on
voit que Google qui a gagné alors
magasin c'est signé
5 tours de 4 tours on s'est arrêté trois
Fougères
et là ça va être sur le défendre
parce que Laurent il se fait mater par
un fou un fils par exemple mais
la dame aura elle
contrôle tout quoi la première rangée
pas en attaque 7 diagonale un H8 en
défense ah c'est marrant comme position
je sais pas
de jouer à un cours mais malheureusement
en fait sur dame j'ai trois ton préféré
tu reprends il faut penser 4 d'ailleurs
même si tu veux encore mieux je menace
prise
tout reprend
voilà l'échange de dames c'est bon
j'ai dit plus en plus
qui faisait un 3 et demi sur 4 en
particulier
[Musique]
c'est vraiment mauvais signe c'est après
il dit que ça fait
en fait
c'est pas la même position
nous sommes d'accord
[Musique]
ça va être nul rapide
allez à un pion de plus mais c'est une
gagnante enfin à ce niveau là sous de la
perdra pas un saut de la perdra pas même
souffle à faire quoi
je
pense
bon normalement c'est pas que j'ai soit
en face ou n'importe qui
où les pions sont genre le 2 contre 1
c'est encore nul mais ça peut se perdre
c'est quand tu as les pions noirs qui
sont hyper avancés là par exemple tu
peux faire G4
et ça va très bien mais si tu laisses le
pur en G2 un moment tu as un réseau de
maths tu vois parce qu'il va pousser F4
G4 puis G3 échecs qui va évidemment pas
faire froid pour pas changer il va faire
j'ai trois et puis tout d'un coup tu as
le droit si je veux manger on me fait
mater ah là là donc c'est pour ça qu'on
conseille de fixer les pions en avançant
un peu pour avoir un peu de stage quoi
comme ça après j'ai quatre tu te prends
un chèque c'est pas grave
mais
je pense
avoir ben si Fabi il est perdu si ça va
faire nul bientôt et ben on va voir qui
est en train de jouer contre Paris
Nakamura il avait annoncé une partie
longue il n'a qu'à moi voilà jauge et la
jauge et ben te fait je pense réussir un
peu ton pari hein tu m'avais annoncé
[Musique]
20h50 Thalassa
[Rires]
c'était pas le programme qui
m'intéressait beaucoup quand j'étais
jeune
j'aimais pas m'informer
mais
où je sais même pas à cette heure là
je me souviens le problème
ok
alors attention
[Musique]
du coup il le bloque par dv3
petit échange quoi
en fait il va te regarder comment c'est
instructif
maintenant
il est pas moins fort que le fou
maintenant et après on va le C4 pour
pour fixer ton fou là on dit ton fou et
ben il joue plus je m'en fous il démarre
c'est très moche
c'est étonnant de faire un coup comme ça
[Musique]
c'est vraiment parce qu'il y a
il y a plein de types de gars je trouve
ça même plus bizarre que le roi
hdoratait par famille quoi
tu crois que c'est pourri tout de suite
tu te prends tu fais ça et cavaler il
est bien meilleur que le fou elle semble
ça je pense à partir elle est elle est
super bien en fait
juste perdu il faut manger un par contre
je pense
dicton fou tu as du F4 qui peut arriver
à F4 en fait
et voilà donc peut-être que l'idée tu
fais des 5 petits règles tu te laisses
le pion passer mais en fait bon
oui ça comme ça moi je pense à cavalier
je m'en fous
même
4 le problème demeure quoi ah je veux
dire à la queue 4 et c'est pas de raison
c'est pas de raison valable pour
vraiment te laisser réouvrir ton fou
moi la raison valable c'est que les
pièces qui restent sont géniales
F3 ou 2 peu importe
on va aller manger les pions un par un
point à trois
trucs comme ça
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de donner le fou mais
enfin de de mais ok en fait tout a l'air
très bien pour les langues et je pense
que il a le cavalier
[Musique]
[Rires]
on va reparti sur oups je fais une
erreur de sur Fabiano et qu'il a
sacrifié la tour et ça il est foutu il a
pas trop le choix que d'essayer de
trouver un perpétuel alors la question
c'est on va où
c'est peut-être pour ça en fait je pense
qu'il a dû voir que ça allait mais il
pense que ça ça va aussi en fait
tu reviens tout recettes
moi je commence à regarder ça mais c'est
ça
va te prendre la peau de banane
à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent en tout
cas bienvenue à tous 5
du Nord-Ouest
il est en forme aujourd'hui à notre
petit
on est là quoi
on est là
en cas d'abandon il a déjà le roi en 5
donc du coup tu as plus que le roi blanc
à mettre sur sur la carte de 4 mais
c'est bon ah c'est pour gagner du temps
non c'est pas grave
[Musique]
il fait encore dépasser dedans au centre
de l'Égypte
bon trois demi sur 4 donc ça veut dire
qu'il avait trois et demi ça fait 9
enfin 3 par victoire donc ça fait 9 et
la particularité
qu'il a fait quoi dans les il avait il
avait gagné il a gagné il avait gagné
donc là il doit il a 17,5
[Musique]
avatar 50 on avait dit quoi qu'on avait
à l'intérieur on avait Magnus Magnus
quoi
du public
de choisir et on va bientôt avoir aussi
la l'Armageddon de de
chevaucher un petit peu tout ça mais bon
déjà 45 il faut le voir parce qu'en plus
et ben on a la caméra sur lui on a c'est
la seule scène où j'ai
où j'ai le
superbe caméra
sur les joueurs
donc on ira la voir à 20h50
sur classement comme
je craque un peu avec
dans ma tête je sais plus qui c'est qui
qui présentait Thalassa mais ça faisait
alors on va parler de je sais pas moi
des
la reproduction des drosophiles en
Alaska voilà et tout ça à 20h50 sur
Thalassa sur France 3 c'était toujours
dans le sens
et du coup
c'était ouais c'est ça
[Musique]
depuis tout à l'heure et du coup c'est
c'est vraiment avec cette
je comprends pas pourquoi Faby
n'abandonne pas en fait
je pense qu'il va se cacher en B6
voilà tac tac tac il va se cacher en
raciste
ou à 8 qu'il avait pas avant un claque à
cause de la tour mais ça me va
malheureusement pas suffire
mange hein
il a pas de temps donc je pense qu'ils
ont un pouvoir
attention hein
[Musique]
attention
de moi 45 est-ce que c'est
ça ça
c'est toujours
là je gagne
plus peut-être c'est le plus simple
damer 8 et 2006
trafons sur cette partie mais
je vais voir si ça a commencé à Magnus
la partie et je vais mettre mon petit
studio et je vais surveiller l'arrivée
de notre ancien champion du monde malins
Carlsen
champion du monde de Blitz et c'est du
Blitz et rapide
l'espace de quelques mois
il a fait combien de fois le triple il a
fait deux fois je crois
3 3
et là c'était la dernière
direction
parce que vous le méritez il vous le
valez bien
entendu je suis
[Musique]
vous mettre une pub je me suis trompé on
part sur ça et je vous mets du coup
Magnus
et ça va commencer
installez-vous
sa catalane version championnat de moi
et la grande ligne
comme ça
on a retrouvé la structure
typique du formidable d'échanges
l'instructure de base
Magnus affectionne avec les deux
couleurs
pour F4
bon ça attaque le plan de 7 mais après
on est pas bien développé du tout pour
l'instant avec les Blancs là encore à
1000 coups de pouvoir faire le petit
rock donc j'imagine le grand coup ça
devait
rapidement je sais plus comment ça
marche mais je sais que des fois on peut
donner le pion à une C5 je crois mais je
sais plus comment ça marche
et j'ai l'impression que guérir
[Musique]
avec pion 2 fois
cavalierdon en cas de match nul en
particulier
Magnus à 10 minutes entre 7 minutes ko
avec juste un incrément d'une seconde
parcours à partir du 40e coup et en cas
de match nul dans l'Armageddon et ben
c'était noir qui l'emporte donc ils ont
moins de temps tout ça
contre Adams une très vieille partie
où il y avait cette ligne
et Carlson avait trouvé un chemin
incroyable de cavalier il avait joué
cavalier froid qui avait les deux
cavalent
non non non je vois très bien que tu
parles c'est un banco c'est sûr que
c'est un banco
on se verra tu me ressens la partie je
suis sûr que ça mène quoi
et ce cavalier cavalier 1 qui empêche
cavaliser
un petit peu
[Musique]
là c'est hyper chaud parce que du coup
il a pas eu le temps de faire son plan
cavalière F3
mais la tour encedes plus contre jeunes
bien c'est noté tu as tu as beaucoup de
gens qui qui sont témoins
de ce qui vient de se passer
comme dans cette partie jouer il y a 16
ans maintenant
alors les Noirs non il y a eu pas mal de
quin blanc aussi un magasin
[Musique]
que tu avais en partie quoi la couleur
tu as plus de temps c'est quand même
deux avantages pour les blancs mais
trois avantages
sauf catastrophe il va il va gagner
tranquillement c'est un magasin
parce que autant dans la partie contrat
d'âme c'est que vous pouvez regarder
pour
accès au chat de switch
autant il avait fallu travailler pour
sortir de la tour de ces deux là elle
est sortie par un coup de développement
donc
[Musique]
donc c'est juste totalement foutu après
il faut convertir mais
bon c'est
la cote de Aniche tiens est très très
élevé
pas mal de gains blancs je pense avoir
magret dans ces harmonies
de faire écrire genre les blancs 10
minutes pour combien de temps tu prends
les Noirs quoi
le système d'enchères
c'est une sorte de camping
[Musique]
j'aime pas du tout
donc
[Musique]
c'était difficile de jouer B3 et là on
peut juste doubler les tours à jouer B3
et voilà après peut-être mais bon c'est
on est en mode survie quoi
il a l'air un peu OK
il sait qu'il a qu'il
a pas bien géré
cette phase d'ouverture à l'ouverture
qui s'est mal passée très mal passée
pour guéri
maintenant là je comprends pas pourquoi
il joue pas à torcer de A5 torsades
[Musique]
et en fait
je comprends le pion passé et protégé
mais la majorités
alors après voilà il faut que le reposer
donc là il va gagner un deuxième pion
parce que Foussais 7
enfin après qu'il allait de 7 pour seul
coup pour protéger le cavalier un peu
plus jouer le foot peut plus jouer donc
c'est atroce
rien fondamentalement au fait qu'il y a
déjà un point de plus et que après faut
C7 les Noirs vont finir par perdre le
pionisme
pour échanger ce plan qui vient faible
qui a gagné on a eu aussi Fabi qui a
finalement cédé sous la pression de
alors voilà ça c'était pas une surprise
mais il y a eu aussi Nakamura qu'il a
emporté sur sur Paris alors par contre
ça
de la gare du coup
on va avoir l'Armageddon entre filles
[Musique]
alors d'ailleurs
je sais plus alors pour le je crois que
est-ce que je sais pas si
je crois qu'il est parti
par rapport au sondage sur un résultat
c'était qui le résultat
abdoukais il y a eu nul mais du coup je
le garde pour le leur magasin j'imagine
et Caro regarde Alicia Hikaru cette
partie là exactement
F4 prise
direct c'est vrai qu'il a laissé le four
en prison il a pas mangé j'avais oublié
ok d'accord ok
ça ça transpose plus ou moins dans ce
qu'on regardait c'est dur pour passer
lié cette option sont très faibles
mais c'est comme si on avait deux en
fait
donc tout réussi des tours des trois on
peut abandonner
en prise si je prends là je perce là et
les Noirs espèrent que les Blancs ont du
mal un peu à pousser le pion et donc
elle tour des cinq pour essayer de me
lasser même pour qu'on cavalier jouer
sur le toit il est blanc ici alors je
pousse mon gros doigt désolé
il y a aussi un clouage ici qui est
assez marrant
et
ça marche comment d'ailleurs c'est ça
voilà
jolie
tu vois ça marche quasiment
et si je mange là il y a ça et ça et ça
et donc en fait il y a ça je défends et
je monte la prochaine
jusqu'au bout il faut se méfier
de la tour ici et le pion contre la case
pardon C8 de la tour C1 donc c'est
gagnant pour Naka qui passe pas par la
case Armagan et donc on a plus qu'une
partie à voir c'est la partie qui va
commencer en 3 minutes la partie de
de fille
[Musique]
moi je m'écoute pas mais apparemment ça
marche pas mal salut Fatou
la prédiction la prédiction
je l'ai pas fait parce que je sais pas
ils ont fait match nul on avait mis soit
blanc gain soit noir enfin voilà on
avait mis les deux et d'ailleurs
tout le monde sauf toi je t'ai pas vu
et donc je lisais que l'Armageddon va
commencer dans 5 minutes je vous mets
donc je pense qu'on va garder la prédit
est-ce qu'on garde la prédit et puis
après je dis comme ça mais bon
[Musique]
je peux vous le montrer regardez
classement il est ici
classement je l'ai un résultat
d'aujourd'hui ça c'est les résultats
et ça a fini le comment je me rappelle
plus
la fin
contre qui a perdu hein qui a fait un
début de tournoi un tronc et qui qui a
perdu là une partie
contre
les raisins ça m'a fait nul et ils vont
s'affronter dans un Armageddon ici une
minute Nakamura qui a fait une partie
tout en souplesse contre oui il est pas
mal je pense qu'il va revenir et hop qui
a perdu un magasin contre cookies les
résultats enfin les le classement est
ici mais il est pas encore terminé parce
que on a des joueurs qui n'ont pas
encore terminé la partie on voit que
carwana a 17,5
on est encore chaud qui a 5 mais il n'y
a pas encore qu'on veut savoir si
et à lireza qui a 6 donc leur points ne
sont pas encore ajoutés donc si
gagne il gagne 1,5 points il passe
troisième quoi
à cette goûtech ah oui pardon c'était
Google je contre Abdou c'était ça la
[Musique]
c'était ça la oui je crois que c'était
Pierrot
on va revenir c'était la partie numéro 3
et l'Armageddon a commencé hein donc 7
minutes pour aller raisin contre 10
minutes pour pour Wesley
obligation de gagner mais pour les
blancs en cas de nul c'est les Noirs
donc allez raisin
trois fois j'ai 5 qui décidément les
fougères
ultra précoce c'est la mode donc là en
plus de plans qu'on mentionné hier dans
une autre partie après faut H4 en plus
de G5 et tout il y a fou 7 aussi qui est
possible
on n'a pas encore je dessine ça va être
là voilà donc faut 7 et jouer et
décidément les raisins il est en forme
[Rires]
j'ai jamais vu aussi en forme
qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cavalier achats
donc
moi c'est la petite idée de Wesley mais
ça je suis pas je suis pas hyper
impressionnée
alors que se passe-t-il
je vous rappelle que bon
sont dans plusieurs interviews il disait
qu'il avait du mal à
passer des parties lentes
obliques juste derrière et c'est vrai
que quand on voit ses résultats en
Armageddon je crois qu'il a tout perdu
ou pas loin mais je crois qu'en normal
[Musique]
une décision intéressante parce que
parce que sinon les noirs n'avaient on
avait juste aucun problème avec Rock qui
avait H5 qui est qui vient donc
on a du mal à y croire quand même
pour de cette très solide
avant ses 15 ans et qu'elle a du mal à
trouver des joueurs
alors déjà il faut que tu regardes en
fait je sais pas où tu habites Alicia
mais il y a plein de clubs autour de toi
je pense sur internet tu peux essayer de
trouver des clubs proches de chez toi
donc tu as sur la Fédération
la possibilité de pouvoir chercher et
regarder un petit peu par région par
ville les clubs proches de chez toi et
puis sinon si tu habites vraiment
vraiment loin c'est avec internet nous
permet aussi de rencontrer des joueurs
et de pouvoir
jouer malgré tout
bon sinon on a donc on a une maintenant
une structure de la d'espagnol par
exemple Steiner à l'ancienne où les
Noirs manquent d'espace mais échangent
toutes les pièces aura qui va y avoir
ensuite cavalier F6 en D7 pour échange
encore plus de pièces et si le blanc
refuse l'échange de fois H4 le fouloir
va se replacer en F6 et le cavalier de 7
pourra ensuite bon dire en ces cinq en
moins 5 il y a une idée ici qui n'a pas
été jouée mais c'était pas mal pour les
pour les blancs c'était d'homme C3 pour
taper sur le plan c'est ça et sur assise
je vois cavaler des cartes et cavaliers
F5 parce qu'en fait le cavalier B5 il
pète bien placé en dessin mais la
meilleure case voilà pas de dames cette
fois ah non mais c'est vrai
ah ouais donc ça ça peur
mais donc enquête tourner a été joué
donc je pense que Firo n'a aucun
problème tu le remets la position du
diable
c'est quand même désagréable pour fil
rouge cette position il est il a très
peu d'espace mais ça reste solide
alors après tu as le plan de
l'avant poste comme dirait
dauphman de jouer
mais idéalement sur quel point de 5 on a
envie de reprendre depuis on sait mais
bon là il est pas encore
c'est juste une structure symétrique
bon et blanc on va très léger plus grâce
à l'avantage d'espace mais il y a plus
beaucoup de pièces
avec quatre pièces mineures chacun sera
très grave la structure pue un cadre
seulement deux pièces mineures chacun
c'est tout à fait supportable
mais ok de toute façon il faut il faut
jouer alors à la pendule ça va bon les
deux jouent aussi rapidement mais donc
pour l'instant elle est sur un bon
rythme
un moment le pion-bessat peut être
attaqué
quand même mais peut-être qu'il jouera
juste pour B8 sur
quoi mais même
je sais pas je voulais te placer mal des
pièces peut-être à 5h
mais maintenant qui a tombé vite en
défense ça va
F4 c'est
avec la tour en E1 et le fond c'est
assez bizarre
mais bon c'est vrai
je comprends ça fait le coup de
Wesley
parce que vous inquiétez pas que c'est
une partie normale il aurait pas joué
parce qu'en fait sur F5 on donne
définitivement la case 5
et si on jouait F4 pour garder le pur F4
ça a l'air très con aussi donc
c'est pas c'est pas un coup
et le pion de 4 aussi pas être faible
je pense et c'est toujours quand même
les 5 jours
et donc est-ce que ça me casse
d'ailleurs
un peu comme une casse forte mais elle
est pas totalement forte en théorie
parce que les Noirs pourraient jouer ces
6 parts c'était vrai en tout cas tant
qu'il y avait le pion à 4 mais c'est le
pion C6
affaiblirait le pion décidé sur la
colonne semi-ouverte donc c'est pour ça
qu'on parle d'avant pas c'est pas une
vraie casse forte parce qu'elle peut
être contre les paramètres mais c'est
quand même une case sympa il peut
difficilement être entraîner par un
purines
[Musique]
alors là E5 là il va quand même se
mettre sous des échanges un jour pour
l'instant je peux pas à cause du clouage
ça peut être pas mal pour les Noirs en
fait parce que F4 ça a quand même pas
mal affaibli la position je me
mal position
F5
mais bon est-ce que c'est possible on
commence à avoir un petit peu chaud
ouais donc voilà par en jouant F5 F5 ça
empêche F5 et sur la prise je mange donc
[Musique]
c'est quoi il peut être
et on n'a pas là il nous manque le foot
case blanche quand même
le cavalier
ah non je sais pas comment savoir un
petit truc
qui commence à être passé mais j'ai ce
fou qui nous fait peur quand même et
je sais pas si je vais la manger là
ok ca va les prendre la logique
et live
ça c'est clair voilà F5 cavalier
comment est-ce qu'il va réussir à mettre
son plan exécution est-ce que dans F3 et
qu'à valider 5 un truc comme ça
je pensais à un truc mais comme tu l'as
eu tout à l'heure ça peut-être ça et un
truc comme ça
si les pions noirs avancent
cette D6 en fait
je me casse Pokémon
je sais pas il y a les thèmes là-haut
comment ça marche
[Musique]
[Rires]
ils ont vu mais du coup là je peux faire
ça
tu vois mais au pire des cas je fais
juste ça et ça et je pense une fois que
je fais des cinq et je domine ton
cavalier et mon fou qui pourra s'activer
quand même
ok prise il va faire nul juste un de
dame C7 derrière attention dame G3 juste
encore
bla bla bla
si je veux défendre il faut que je pense
de du
cloison
5 voilà c'est ça
oui mais les blancs doivent gagner en
fait
gagner et c'est il reste 9 coups pour
avoir un incrément d'une seconde ce qui
est pas énorme mais au moins c'est un
incrément qui me permet de pas tomber
enfin d'avoir moins de chance de tomber
plutôt et de 44 pour Ali resa contre 3
48 pour pour Wesley mais j'imagine
qu'après d'un panda mais tu reprends F5
qui a très peu de chance de gain pour le
blanc quasiment zéro
est un peu mieux hein
c'est peut-être même moi qui pousse cinq
cavaliers
sont limites quasiment mieux en fait
si jamais je fais et du coup roi je veux
ah c'est bien trouvé ça
sa force
et en fait tu rentres à la maison mon
cher et ici c'est ma tante
c'est très joli je crois que c'est
maintenant
ah non c'est moi qui par rapport
excuse-moi j'avais vu ça moi je voulais
être maté comme ça mais malheureusement
on remet la partie là parce que
par contre
je crois
mais je suis pas très très loin
attention
c'est pas très très loin en même temps
quand même
ça reste quand même pas mal pour
en fait
et la privé 7 waouh mais en fait il a
peut-être raison en pratique il se dit
bon je suis vraiment entendu
la position
[Musique]
en fait tu pouvais jouer un peu de
contrôle
B5 et tout
garder la situation est décimétrique
donc
après
[Musique]
il y a des attaques de
perpétuels là on voit G4
[Musique]
je vais faire ça
et en fait
échec voilà échec on mange là il va
manger celui qui veut je mange là il
mange là et je mettrai ma tour ici et
puis
c'est encore plus facile
il est très en forme aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ça va être ça va être drôle
pas du tout comment il peut avoir au
moins une chance de bien à part autant
dans 45e coup il y a un incrément
maintenant
[Musique]
et ils vont pas les perdre mais
on peut dire à quel point c'est
chaque fois il va perdre 3
enfin après on s'en fout tant que tu es
là si tu perds et nul c'est pareil tu
peux tenter
ça lui rapporte un demi point qui peut
être précieux vu qu'il joue pas la gare
et demi et le leader Fabienne
petit à petit ils s'en rapproche et donc
voilà tu as le classement les deux
Américains en tête Fabiano carwana 17000
il avait le même score avant sa trompe
mais il a perdu en classique et Caro
Nakamura 9 ennemis sur 15 à les raisins
fujoja notre français troisième seul
troisième
quatrième place cinquième execo charia
mahammediaf et ou cache qui ont 7 points
Magnus qui n'a toujours pas gagné une
partie lente et qui en a perdu même une
est execo avec Annie Jerry et Wesley
et un pour terminer orientari le joueur
local qui a seulement deux petits points
mais en même temps quel temps noir
difficile pour lui quand elle est la
cible de tous les autres joueurs quoi et
que tu n'as aucune journée facile
voilà pour pour l'étiquane on va on va
on va regarder un petit peu rapidement
les Armageddon moi j'en ai un ici les
Noirs ont gagné mais ils ont gagné
par par gain sur le chéquier
ma manière off qui a gagné avec les
Blancs
est-ce qu'on la conte de temps contre
c'est pas une tu vois quand tu dis les
Noirs gagnent dans le sens nul quoi non
[Musique]
il a gagné parce qu'il a il a mieux joué
donc il a gagné que les Noirs
qui a gagné les blancs contre Paris ici
on voit SOC a gagné les blancs donc
première ronde il y a quand même par
rapport à ton à ce que tu nous dises il
y a zéro non c'est équilibré
ils ont mis quelques années à trouver la
cadence sur 7 32 Magnus qui a gagné les
blancs
OK et ensuite
final qui gagne avec les noirs qui
gagnent parce qu'il a mieux joué que
guéri malheureusement c'est toujours
celui qui perd et donc là encore une
fois on a la ronde 2 tu as aucune nulle
comme quoi j'ai eu l'endage d'avoir les
Noirs parce que là il a gagné par la
mieux jouer d'accord mais il a pas du
tout
gagné sur une île avant de 3 on a Magnus
qui gagne avec les noirs avec chacun
mince donc encore une fois je vois pas
où est-ce qu'on a profité du système
en l'air etc mais attention c'est un
système équilibré et après ça dépend des
joueurs ça dépend du style mais
c'est pas que l'Armageddon et en soi des
équilibré tu vois il y en a qui disent
souvent ça a été 5 minutes contre 4 puis
4 minutes chaos et après là on disait
non mais c'est trop pas avantageux pour
les pour les blancs certains disaient
les Noirs
mais en vrai en vrai le but c'est de
trouver la bonne cadence et donc là si
les organisateurs aidaient des joueurs
tous les meilleurs du monde qui se
réunissent pour trouver la bonne cadence
le blanc 10 minutes il faut combien en
noir pour s'assurer calibrer ils ont dit
7 ohms et puis si c'est pas cette
précise c'est vraiment pas loin de 7 ans
après il faut un départage leur magasin
ça reste assez intéressant et là
franchement on voit des résultats blancs
noirs nuls et c'est vrai que les Blancs
jouent plus pour le gain c'est que les
Blancs perdent des parties parce que ben
ils peuvent pas faire mieux ça c'est
vrai je suis d'accord mais d'un autre
côté vous avez un avantage de temps il y
a une cadence qui est forcément bonne et
si c'est pas dice versus 7 c'est quelque
chose de très proche de ça quoi
mais ça reste indépendance qui est en
tout cas assez intéressant quoi donc je
pense que il faut il faut rester là
dessus en tout cas je vois je pense que
ça ne reste qu'un si tu penses
devrait avoir moins bah pourquoi pas il
y a un argument pour dire c'est 6
minutes 45 moi j'en sais strictement
rien mais
il faut voir sur quel stade hyper
précise et basé c'est
cette hypothèse parce que en l'absence
de cette hyper précise pourquoi enfin
moi j'ai envie de faire confiance aux
organisateurs et à Magnus et à tous les
joueurs qui ont décidé que c'était 7
minutes le plus précis quoi
[Musique]
merci à vous tous d'avoir suivi le
stream et écoute moi je te dis à bientôt
Yoshi à bientôt nous on se revoit demain
à partir de 17h pour la rendre 6 comme
d'hab pour moi et à bientôt
et bonne soirée à tous et à tous
à bientôt